welcome everybody to another episode of
the h3 podcast live today we have an
amazing show I usually say that but
today it's truer than ever
okay you guys remember them for the last
episode Eric from internet comment
etiquette is rejoining us with a new
segment Eric's conspiracy closet that's
right I'm very excited that's going to
be later when you're talking about flat
earth and all of the wonderful believers
and proponents of it yeah a little bit
later we have Dan what do we call it
what was our name for it
mm then the second nudes send it then
then send me news will be doing the news
again a little bit later after that
we're here with you of course but here's
where [ __ ] gets weird and wild does not
give me enough to hear you right here's
where [ __ ] gets weird and wild humongous
is here from Seattle the legend came to
LA to join us for the specific reason of
joining us here on the podcast I'm
honored I'm blessed it's a treat to have
you here really thanks for coming out
and joining us I'm so excited to have
you thank you either this is I'm truly
honored myself I made it pinch me if I'm
not in LA because I know I'm definitely
not in Seattle and you're not in see
I've actually had a Mexican chauffeur
pick me up and yeah I mean I just felt
like a right at home I'm used to the
Nordics where I come or I live and then
all of a sudden I'm going wow it looks
like jr. hey it looks like compadre also
looks like a ma what is it not a lot of
Mexicans yeah well there are but it's a
where I live
they've slowly started migrating and so
not very made I'm the original Mexican
gardener from Ballard in North original
the original Mexican every gardener from
Ballard before they were cool everybody
wants a mad dog I don't like it because
I've got too much competition well when
we got it we now we got your end we got
your advertising on deck Rudy's
gardening what's the name of your colors
Pantoja is garden patio has garden now
you guys you know I've made a make sure
than that that so
people that think I've been brainwashed
by the Nordics understand that Nordics
don't brainwash me because they're
lutefisk
if you mean if I were to eat the
lutefisk that I could say they're very
wash me but you're talking about the
inhabitants of Seattle
yeah the lutefisk is a fish it's a it's
a specialty that the base of their
people's food but your people food do
they pronounce you two-piece music dude
maybe went into the video today before
we get too deep in this conversation
let's have a give a quick thank you to
Adult Swim who sponsoring this episode
brought to you by them and the newest
season of Rick Morty out July 30th
mm-hmm God blossom nature's box
delicious wonderful snacks the black tux
liquors hex suits and tuxes and Vince
arrows classy affordable watches more on
that later supposed to do that at the
beginning but I get so wrapped up in
this incredible episode I just got but
we'll talk about that later we're
capable to see that ad now this yeah
yeah the cold opened in there and now
let's plot some ready yeah anyway can
you believe that Adult Swim is paying us
to promote Rick and Morty what is again
we'll talk about is one of the best
shows on television is unbelievable it's
so great but any rate you're talking
about a fish oh yeah I was a fish not
let the fake willies that I had in the
back at the truck have you tried it I've
never got yet it's actually a love Rika
Irene is a fermented herring herring
yeah they call Terry it's a it's a IOT
well the social justice lawyers seem
that they connect they think up from the
northern part of Norway and they because
there are brown Norwegians in the
northern part of Norway but no there's a
conspiracy theory that you're from
Norway that's what the today they want
you to be white they want me to be and
last time I checked I'm not and I won't
go any farther than that I mean I
there's a lady in the house what it
would is your background it's Mexican
American uh
grandparents are from
Mexico and my mom on the offside got the
the German and the Native American Wow
and it was always funny we'd be around
our grandma who's dark-skinned I got my
mom's eyes grandma's eyes and tell ya my
grandma used to be called different
names back in the 60s and 70s and she
would throw a fit
oh my god your grandma was wet Native
America okay and she was dark and
grandpa was this tall german guy and she
was she would get called different and
we don't serve people look like they're
in Jesus she's like big a tall like 5
feet 6 feet 5 foot tall and she would
just snap she'd say what'd you say
what'd you say okay rich you know I
don't want to swear cuz I could know the
kids like kids I don't want to give all
I get here today
you know funny she did swear granny
granny was a melty piece of work I find
it pretty interesting that your family
actually faced real like the Native
Americans talk about a group of people
who got absolutely [ __ ] over harder
than anyone and here they're there like
they want you to be sweet or like
Norwegian well it's because I'm educated
and our grandma the Mexican side she'd
always say English English around the
babies know I spend y'all know I said no
and she was really adamant about it and
our aunts and uncles would be speaking
as bad as she cut him off and say
education education English though in
high school I took Japanese identity
okay my Nissan chico Roxy sauce couldn't
you you got you JIT that sanity is far
you know that's that's me home go
Japanese plate we all thought that that
humongous was totally adorable but now
you're kawaii
to new love you know quiet that's
adorable oh boy yeah well oh my god and
you have that Hardee's
yeah oh oh I love it
you're truly a mr. interactional well I
try to be you know but people go to me
why don't you go to Mexico I said well
my in-laws on the beach Oh God
restaurant a right there crowd hell if I
go there that's Mexico once you go to
Greece we'll talk he's mad Greek in
there Greece there Greek and they have
the belly dancers on Friday nights and I
go rolling in
Oh rude he sit down sit down and
handsome dog roll it in some lamb and
I'm sitting there and then touch it to
get it dead and it's just killer
I mean how exciting why is this podcast
there who sounds pleased we shady and
yeah I've often how do you like Seattle
like do you I've always everyone who's
been there tells me it's such an
incredible place it's absolutely
incredible place there's that 30 minutes
for the mountains right next to the
water
bully problem is we've got a lot of
outsiders coming in and telling somebody
like me it was 55 years old I grew up in
Seattle how to act and behave and
especially when it was I swear god I
have to make this clear that 30
something year old female to jump my ass
we don't haul she nah I say in her name
she she jumped my ass and and I and she
needed to know respect for the elders I
mean I would not do that to her but
where she came off everything in my
power not to color well you handle
yourself with grace but I want to get
into that I find out whole thing really
interesting you grew up in Seattle you
you were there your whole life pretty
much right pretty yes and so you and so
these people like like xarna can we say
your name really like spooky they're
going to like dig in like flying here on
a broomstick like in Harry Potter's and
should like Lord Voldemort she says how
many places I have actually maybe I
don't know I mean up but you're saying
they came like do you know where she's
from how long she was there you know I
don't know I had never seen her I had a
look up social justice order maybe
that's how that's how dumb I was I mean
so I looked up social justice where I go
what's that she's white I mean I had to
actually figure this stuff out with a
with a flip phone
so and I mean I was like I didn't even
see any videos until like a week later
and that that day that I left it was
already on CBS Radio and I hadn't heard
that either I'm asking what's going on
and I get a call from the Yemen's Arabs
and buffalo hey GRU dog man you're
famous I said what are you talking about
it will star him up I will sew him up I
said what's that I'll send you a link so
I got this looking at my flip phone and
I'm going well I got something but I'm
not sure how to turn it on now I do I
humongous forced me to change in so many
ways I it was a gift how I came here was
a gift I can't I don't even question it
but one of my questions for you too is
like the does you become like the legend
the legend of humongous and I'm really
curious how like that becoming like that
new person of like humongous has
affected your life because I've seen
like on our subreddit you're
participating in like school plays to
make a school plays about you you're
running for City Council and you're
almost like this mythical figure it
seems like around Seattle and I'm really
curious how much did it did this whole
ordeal change that you're right I think
what would it would it hit me right wait
it goes back to the 90s when we stuck
fake Willie and the Ballard Locks to
scare the sea lions because all the way
balcony goes to 90 late night that's
when the legend was born
yeah was the New York Times called me
Seattle Civic prankster and by the way
if you guys don't know what he's talking
about there was an image of you with a
giant killer whale and the back of your
truck and you're trying to like pawn it
it was young had medical bills and I
thought we made the whole fun way right
it was I was desperate to make sure that
this medical was paid at least my
insurance and I wanted to pay it like
two or three months in advance to allow
my hip to to heal and so I put it in the
back of the truck driving it around
doing got yard service leaf blowing and
stuff and I had it offered 500 bucks and
I wasn't going to give it up for fire
could go
hock might blower you know I mean forget
that I'm not going to you know pawn off
my tools I need my tools and I'm not
going to give away the people's whale
for five hundred articles with the
people I will and so so now that was so
it's worth I saw the people's well for a
thousand I was going for I was going
neighbor for 35 to 5 and I think he
didn't he did you get anywhere I guy I
was close I got really what was the most
Auto dive 2500 and who's gonna buy I'm
the first talk about sticking it on top
of a casino sign well I go well would
take Willy is not through not a gallon
kind you know excited I wouldn't be the
best this is the people's whale and yes
and she is now it's a female Orca she's
now at the Ballard Locks in Seattle and
she's on display but the history of how
she came from Scotland to Seattle and
how the local KISW rock'n'roll is
donated to the fund to bring as well and
stick it in the Ballard Locks to use a
scarecrow and we were calling it people
interested saving steelhead sea lions at
the Ballard Law my god that's a acronym
for something that was not very popular
at the time what was that cream stand
frankly than that piss at the logs one
last shot before you shoot piss at the
logs at the locks Ballard Locks Wow and
and and if we were going give it one
last shot one last shot before you shoot
and the PTA moms just went ballistic
cause you need to take that down so we
did a vote on the air with the KISW rock
and roll listeners Bob Rivers twisted
radio and we go what do you think early
those politicians you know what we the
name stands we support people interested
so we took a democratic voted estate and
so that's the history of it and did it
past the name remain degree oh yeah the
listeners were it was overwhelming and
so I called up the council members down
at City Hall and I said I just want you
to know that you're outvoted and the
name stands
people's will stands that stands
interested sounds like you're just such
you're like a Seattle troll oh I just I
just troll around a gardener they're
garters you don't like June was born I
could definitely do it all and we've
incense in it you'd be in the local
gardener it's been called a como Chile
rude dog the ladies would go oh Road dog
you want to go play some golf
Oh facing my mom the mom it's actually
funnier than stuff they say that oh yeah
Oh root dog
oh I cannot and that goes out the window
there's no I know I mean I'm in the
pickup truck in it just that was that
was something that's happened over the
years and but this humongous thing it
was a slip of the tongue the smirk the
smirk if you only knew what I was
thinking in my head on the smirk its I
had to stall was it let's get into mine
well I was faking H M teats
hmtl Eve my name is H M Q M teak's
hue mt but what happened is wait what
does that mean I've been stead of so I
cut out the teats and put mungus slipped
out of my mouth instead of going HM but
what did you what was it supposed to be
what was supposed to be humongous taints
a humongous teeth that's still not that
bad but I didn't say it I was going to
but I see I was it when I said it and I
wasn't I backed off and I get to smirk I
said don't say it she went oh this is a
domestic dispute seriously looking ready
to go to have a conniption fit con tizzy
bad and so I was just thinking about my
hip walking out that door getting down
the stairs getting away from this battle
ax I mean young woman and boy did she
just she kept egging me on
she was looking this is what they do
these social justice warriors they go in
there and they're looking for any
morsel of outrage they can find and it
almost doesn't even matter what you
would have said I don't think so much
they're just there looking there they're
like sifting for gold nuggets and they
just found something to latch on to and
you happen to be that you could have
said Rudy my name is Rudy what me what's
already great world yeah oh boy this
would have been in my mom's house give
it her hurrying in his stuff and then
get mom involved in those women on her
block not very supportive is lately a
young lady it would not be very
supportive maybe 70 aftermath was was
not these guys it was I'm like catching
up a little bit I think a little caught
up I think the the initial video of your
conference race calm confident set a
stroke Caucasian
part of me was what blew up on the
Internet we're huge on Reddit and
everything and a lot of people were
talking about it like look at this
insane lady harassing this guy but she
posted he posted on her Facebook page
everyone was like what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you why would you promote this it
makes you look insane and she erased it
and then someone ripped it from Facebook
put it on YouTube and the rest is his
but at first you got hey right well I
did that you love her group for her you
know what was interesting is that she
any any time being a public figure or
running for office usually get the
hitters it's a social norming at the
hater something they don't call you up
sort of the walk by you spit on your
sneeze on you um / you've never been
spit on em yeah they oh yeah and then I
got a lot over this but but it's a but
it happens taking a stance and Cl and
then you're going to crazy nut heads and
they're on both sides I mean I thought
one side you know one side so it's both
sides absolutely and it's Rudy in the
minute and I like I like my little place
where I am being the Garter but I what
ischl II the reaction before it hit the
internet was that was that xarna and her
friends posted in
their community to be like look at this
[ __ ] guy who sexually harassed me and
the police kicked me out so at first it
was all hate on oh you're laid you feel
that before everyone was like wait hold
on this is backwards to see what I did
is I actually took a complaint to the
office of civil right you did the ACLU
being I had my Arab friends from the
Arab community that wanted me to get an
attorney to sue her because uh really
should be able to just add and no ID but
they were calling it slanderous and then
when they when she started the
anti-immigrant stuff she didn't realize
that there are people that come from
outside of the country that live here
now that asked me to take their kids and
get them enrolled in Seattle Public
Schools or help their mom or their Gramp
the elders with medical and stuff like
that I have a problem doing that I'm a
gardener flexible and had no idea that I
was a single dad and she didn't have any
idea that because I speak fluent English
and I sound American
that I was Hispanic if she tried to rip
me she tried to rip me down for anything
and everything and she's anything she
couldn't she couldn't that was one of my
favorite parts about that interaction
was that she's like she's like oh are
you like we saw recently the footage
from inside the council which I want to
watch with you because we recently made
a video about it but might like
dissecting the way they attacked you is
really fascinating because at first
they're like oh you're white and then
you're like no I'm not white and so that
doesn't make them feel like oh maybe I
was wrong they go oh then you're a token
Hispanic you're not white but your token
Hispanic and it's like you know and then
it's like well why do you want more
police and you're like will they help my
daughter it's like you have a legitimate
answer to all their hit job questions
and it's like that their tension is so
clear because it never it makes them
reconsider it just makes them go full
force more there's so many of us in the
Hispanic community that do call the
police when we need a problem because
that's the right thing to do we're not
afraid of law enforcement and the other
thing is when people like her
organization calls me token
for the whites and I'm Hispanic what it
does is is it dumps down our kids
because I'm telling the kids a education
you know if you can't do that if you
can't read you can't do the math you
can't do the science you can't get a job
and no money no honey
oh really realize that your baggage that
is good I said if you want that honey
and you want the money learn to read do
the math and do the science listen your
teachers and your parents and be have
fun so what is what is it that by
labeling you as a token what like token
Hispanic how does it undermine that if
you can't I mean she it's just her own
opinion and and and her little groupies
over here that try to push it and they
try to push it on everybody across the
board and I'd really like and I'm it's
hard to stand up to him because they'll
they'll go as far as to want to boycott
a business or or really a family member
label you as a sexual assault sir and
thank God that I have enough diversity
and might around me that knows who I am
I mean if I did something wrong I would
have near to arrest me you hold me
accountable but in this case she was off
her nut crazy and and I don't mean
anything hard well or mean-spirited
toward her but she could probably use a
diversity training for herself in
learning about others and if she's going
to practice what you preach sister and
the COO is that most important thing is
is she did have some legitimate things
to talk about right I'm some women
issues and I understand right it's a no
brainer let's shove it down my throat
and say that I don't care well not in
the way she did I don't know how you
have a debate which and I like when they
were there presenting their case at the
City Council they're like we don't think
that we should spend two hundred million
dollars on a police station we can spend
this money in a better way which is like
that's a valid point and I agree I
actually agree with that I did if you
know when I went there it wasn't
primarily for the precinct I just
happened to show up it had to do with
the precinct we would
talking about it but that numbers
skyrocketed versus what it was before if
it has a special interest eating it was
it was like maybe right around 80
million dollars in the beginning 9
million and then other special interest
one a community club in a community room
and stick grass on top and then place
where they can work out with the cops
and that particular corridor is known
for prostitution and heroin and drugs
and trafficking women and you guys
weren't even necessarily even in
disagreement and it's come back like she
was there for her reason I was there to
think the North Precinct and I had no
idea there was a protest interest I just
showed up to a protest you walk and I go
free and then I then I look at the
because I actually was ready to leave I
was going to take off because I didn't
want to have kind of shit-stirrer happen
ships to happen in that and I was like
13th on the list and I go well you know
what I'll just
oh you're 13 I was like 13th on the list
so I can I know I can hang so I said
amongst them in the beginning and I had
a council staffer come up to me and
shake my hand and say how's your
daughter I mean the council staffer knew
why what why I was there and then when
it came time to look at my interest they
all bailed on me I couldn't even get the
video from them I had to look it up yak
tonight now seeing City Council wouldn't
suppose that is didn't I don't think
they wanted it to get out and got out
they got out finally I was fast it was
because there were two sides that
happened before that exchange and and
even the exchange before I went on with
: News television she was harassing me
and myself in the reporter from une como
ABC and I said miss back off I'll talk
to you after I told her please back off
yeah because this in and then she had
her camera right in but anyways it's I
have to think I I really swear I think
the kids the kids that saw that video
were the ones NCL across the country and
around the world stood up for me when my
own City Hall left
abandoned me in favor of something that
was in just truly ingested injustice and
wrong I mean nobody has it's not fair
for anybody to go in and and try to
testify and share the express themselves
in a democratic process it just hacks I
mean use the word hack it hacks me off
to know and absolutely and I don't don't
kid yourself I really wanted to color an
F and B but I didn't I held off or held
back it's such a wonderful thing you
didn't do that I think that if you first
of all I think he would have been
justified saying that but the fact that
you didn't really held you up to such a
higher level than her is what made the
whole battle so symbolic and wonderful
but like what was happening in the the
City Council was really was I was in
disbelief when I saw that recent video
because you're just a guy who went to
participate in our democratic process
which is something you don't really see
in people these days and the fact that
like um they don't even listen it's
they're there to like for like
ideological warfare it's not like a
fruitful debate it's not like a civil
society it's a real symptom of like a
disease I feel like in our culture that
you you try to make a fruitful effort to
debate and participate in democracy and
you're faced with that but what I what
I've noticed is it's the same people
going to that same meetings whether it's
a council chamber meeting or community
meeting they bum-rush them and then they
take over the the hearing and and don't
allow people to speak who may not agree
with them Wow I mean it happens all the
time where we've lost people who have
had great ideas to say I'm going to bag
this I'm sick of it and we even had
several business owners that were
boycotted where who stepped away from
ownership to protect their their
businesses and taken again after me they
came out it is and and what's
interesting there are council staffers
that hand out the lists of different
meetings and it gets sent out shotgun
approach through the
she's a different group he weathered
anarchists or and other special interest
groups right and then we get blab and
blacklisted they've you know I'm a
threat to you have yet I mean come on
I'm a are just really schmuck and at
Roger pictures all like whoa FA oh my
god man oh my gosh we'd already for
Seattle City Council and going around
the different forum and events hang on
hazel yeah Martha you know that man's
our sexual harasser yes Charlotte
letters like oh nice yeah I'm all coy
you know I've Rudy with the freakin
Shamu in the back of there the rest of
national security really why I'm
experienced suck it no kawaii kawaii how
do you say quite quite quite I'll never
get that happen right neither a second
okay but what do you think's going on
with the City Council because it seems
like in a way these this mafia so I'm
like a mafia of outrage at this point
are they like they putting so much
pressure on them do you think they're
just like don't even want to deal with
their insanity so in a way they're
they're influencing them do you think
that they're genuinely influencing them
or it's more influence of I don't want
to deal with this mafia I'm scared of
this mafia somehow they've got that
entrenched with other special interest
and what we're going to see coming in
2018 is more Seattle shenanigans and if
I was a comic if I was a comedian you
are I would definitely feed up their
their agenda and because there's money
to be made off that Seattle City Council
just doing doing different spoofs or
twisted things every doing like there it
is insane I mean the I actually spoke
with the chairwoman that was at the
meeting that cut me off try to talk to
her last week in West Seattle forum I
cannot talk to you about this I'm really
busy and I can tell you know and and you
know I can't be associated with you
because I'm worried about what the other
may think Rudy you know I can tell the
vibe
scuse me you know what you're you're a
threat to Mike my campaign we have
people like you I said you're Hispanic
your mother's face with a camera that's
what would have no world's larget you
need to get in her face and film our say
you are you if you do not talk to me I
will tell the world your sex or harass
her and you grab my penis like it that
was it you got to play their game right
well well the the following meeting she
showed up to the other lady the the
social justice showed up in work she got
kicked out of the council meeting she
actually got kicked out I saw that she
she attacked she went after that
Councilwoman and went after the
african-american council chairman the
President of the Council and he kicked
her out he had enough and but that there
are so many of them that think they can
go in and disrespect the process and
I've always been somebody to respect the
process I don't care whether it's public
or private you know there's two sides
it's not one way that's how it works
that's what was so traumatic to watch
that City Councilman you have to respect
the process that's how it works I mean I
don't know one sighs respect you on one
side is not there interrupting you there
screeching did you want to watch yeah I
do want to watch that sound like there's
about isn't that the for a few dollars
more a Clint Eastwood movie that screech
oh there's a screech in that movie have
you seen it I've known about the screech
to the streets where I think Tuco or
what's his name is Clint leaves them
hanging on the tree and then he shoots
the rope off and he falls down like
round the neck I think there's a screech
in there that's what it reminded me of I
think that's that look I turned around
that is I heard that read oh I want to I
have so many questions about that video
I do want to watch it but I want to act
yeah you want to watch you know so if
you guys don't know what we're talking
about yes we there was a basically a new
video that came out a couple weeks ago
that hit the internet I guess you were
trying to get it and they wouldn't give
it to I don't know they were just they
were just I don't know where you could
get the video it's crazy because it
literally
so one-sided and to be even completely
Frank before I had access to this video
I did wonder what would happen in there
because they were so upset and I was
like I wonder if Rudy made some kind of
remark that upset them I wondered that
if there was two sides to the story
because usually there are I'm a
skeptical person but getting this
footage and seeing it I was just like
completely exonerated in my mind a
hundred percent like man they are so so
rude and out of line here half of the
stuff that they were saying where I was
trying to speak and I mean it was pretty
I mean I'm tough as nails you know
nothing like kidnap we need to rock with
a weedeater right in a frigging between
the eyes and say oh yeah or hitting cat
pies out there in the garden and that's
enough tonight
Oh dogs know not dog cats the word catch
oh no that is just now it's worse than
human worse the dog what's the web I'm
at it has just it it just sticks for a
weedless again it goes into the skin and
then you can taste it coming out of the
mouth ah and what it is hold on hold on
let's get into this just so you're
talking about you're hitting along with
the weed whacker yeah I should blow cat
[ __ ] everywhere haha it gets right on
the note it gets right here the cheek
and it goes through the cheek and then
to anything gross always goes like
straight for the mouth Amir right here
he's like it's got like a mind of its
own yeah well you know Ellis brother has
a theory that water is a conscious being
and I wonder if I go with the [ __ ]
getting in your mouth yeah it wants to
go back home it was like puckered in
underneath a leaf in the in on the grass
and I'm going you know that looks kind
of fishy down there now screw it I'll
just add it Oh admit it Candida let's
get it on the boat lawn mower wheel
that's even worse because they get to
keep it travels with us everywhere we go
I mean it's just you're selling me the
cat [ __ ] goes and penetrate your skin
and then travels into your mouth I'll go
through the mucous through the body your
body absorbs it serves it and you can I
can actually taste it coming out and
touching you're forgetting the second
ball it's like we always be like yeah
it's like get one of those nicotine
patches you know it would be right
something like that it's like a - it's a
cat patch you I want to find a
marketable product is pretty bad cat put
inside cat know aviation reproduction
storage a new March available guys
putting ads couldn't add anyway that was
a great tangent why your cat such
disgusting creature I hate cats
I hate their spit their smelled like
poison if you order out I don't really
care
have you ever been around a cat and you
know I've been sprayed by them okay so
you can say yeah I don't know that i
don't doubt how they their piss smells
like chemical warfare yeah not even
their tongues are cool their tongues are
like spiky hair brushes yeah I've
slurred that [ __ ] cats [ __ ] at moving on
so anyway this is the video we're
talking about this is the epic prequel
to humongous - humongous churning can we
hear it in here damn Tony's turn up the
TV
what okay I believe it's room breach
Calvary hotel huh jr. I live in the
North pen grew up in the north and we
moved here
1969 grew up on 109th in Aurora
I am totally for a safe learning healthy
environment in the North End I know the
North dang you're saying as a kind of a
rough North it is a it's a population
that covers over a third of the
population of Seattle okay
maybe even closer almost maybe half well
and we're under served as an earth in
and as you live there I love you know
that here is my neighborhood and and and
I've seen changes over it since years
I've grown up there and of course I'm
going to defend and and we just recently
had a young man still 84 year old
grandma's purse off the street he was a
known addict and everybody's looking for
a man and somebody sent me a post from
New Jersey about it being humongous it's
cool I get this post like health god I
know him
and
we know him and been trying to get him
help for a while just and can't get him
help but he and but did that's the kind
of thing I like to do is as I'm
gardening see somebody down let's hey
you know there's services for you are
you ready for it
Appy oh okay then you're not ready to go
to jail I mean that's it you want or the
other and it's same way if I came and
Jack you up and or or hila up or you up
and because I'm going out to get a fix
I'd like oh well that's well you know
what hey well you know what let's
forgive him because you know it's not
his fault it's all your fault that you
happen to be there right now it's good I
don't know about that it doesn't work
that way well you're you're basically
moving for more support more facilities
I mean there's no precinct in your
neighborhood we have one little one okay
and it is outlived its its ability to
take care of our NYADA North End and
nothing would be not every a lot better
sick in a precinct maybe maybe I
definitely not the one that they plan to
build that one is ginormous like a
military base I mean I'm just but it's
just too many special interest people
wanting to spend extra dollars at we
don't have I'm fascinated by the fact
that you actually agree with their on
that spending point I actually do right
there no but she wouldn't [ __ ] shut
up enough to actually listen and finally
you guys have common ground like most
people do well there's no way I mean I
don't even think we could have it now
because I'm going to turn all oppressor
areas words
hate against women got about aggression
is that Oh does that mean oh man there
was a whole grade yeah I got what I'm
doin all for eternal internal interns
elders gosh I almost I remember the
definition we made a whole video about
it because she made a rental oppressor
yeah internal oppression it's just about
how like if I'm if I don't think that is
being sexist I things and like I am
eternally uh oh okay what like like a
procession and if I'm not offended yeah
if I'm not Amanda
then wrong with me yeah that's right all
right all right right right so it's this
whole [ __ ] up notion that women who
aren't outraged by Rudy's behavior than
their internally utterly oppressed so
it's like you are being oppressed you
just don't know it yeah so she made this
whole video calling out to the whole
female population saying you're
internally oppressed yeah it's like they
do like they have amazing mental baby
save that for when it works like I'm
sure as examples of that is or something
yeah yeah it's probably like you know
maybe no fan of Bill Cosby it might be a
little bit of meat back on yeah maybe
maybe what he did is she totally cheated
a naturally sexual harassment or right
or even somebody that is sexually abused
and it's just not I mean literally if
you're going to say something say
something legitimate that's not over
Rudy it's in Maui I mean that's just a
bunch of crap now that is such an
important didn't you talked to the kids
and whether they want to teach the kids
this stuff they're wanting to get in
Seattle Public Schools and teach social
justice warrior ism I go yeah me I go
you got to be kidding me I couldn't
believe it
I learned this on the campaign lesson
one kids outrage
what is outrage and went to experience
it that's all the time that's when you
wear a humungous t-shirt into school the
first day of school and they go what is
that you can't wear that kids usually
guys like a big let's say anything right
I think I'm gonna be like the Antichrist
in their new religion oh well you want
your enemy little bit greater with all
gardening can no longer be a profession
I was actually walking down sup Lavetta
as I you say is up within a Boulevard of
suppose but up to pull but I yes
whenever so I'm walking down I'm at the
way Express I go walking in and some
young boy is a african-american ago she
ma s mungus you're my hero man one of
the the people behind the counter said
are you humongous I said yeah and they
saw versus having a group photo that was
kind of well they said
Benji said tell Ethan I said hi he's the
man
dingy little thank you what about you
god bless him um oh alright let's let's
continue for us where were we
if you roll precinct I believe it's a
positive move is our public safety north
of the ship you know I have plenty of
people that's supportive of all
different backgrounds in the North Zone
yeah that's the first wonderful
interruption where are they I couldn't
say their names because they would chase
my dogs through the street like they're
like vampires going after suck their
blood you know what are they social
justice vampires checking your blood or
something like that that's a good fight
I think about like a social justice
warrior start looking
I'll run but have you come out of bat no
vampire
oh Carlos I know at yamaga's that's what
our look in your pockets our lick throw
at them I'll try that the next time
thank you here two girls got a lot of
GMOs and I said you know yeah that's
filled with can yet just say no violin
and massive loads of girl oh yeah I'm
here no no interrupting the other
speakers please I want to see it as is I
want to thank the North Precinct for
getting my heroin addicted daughter off
the street and failing her an
opportunity to get boy she's Latino with
a power really [ __ ] me off yeah I bit
my tongue it's so insulting I'd also
like you're talking about your daughter
who had a real trouble in life and then
they take the opportunity to attack you
it's like they have no boundary but she
did say what it is dear when I spoke to
her about it she did say what does white
have anything to do with addiction yeah
it's all communities have addictions
right and so I mean if somebody has an
addiction let's help get them off the
street right regardless I mean it
doesn't matter doesn't matter I mean
addiction is addiction and and that's
how I look at it too
I mean I think that's a very brilliant
point on her perspective being with
friends that are late who said that
my daughter Mike hey Dad was revising
this what does white have to do with
anything addiction to all communities
and they said yeah I know
and so it's like they're the ones that
are so obsessed with race in a way that
it's it's ridiculous I mean it just I
just if I have a hard time listening to
them because they they've cheapened
they've cheapened it and they've made
excuses for our young to not try to
achieve in school because of legitimate
true maybe social to social justice
issues but in Seattle we all work
together we support one another but
there are certain people that are
[ __ ] we always have dick ass and
then when you call them get rid of
[ __ ] is call them a [ __ ] and
shut the [ __ ] up you know we don't need
to hear your stupid dumb ass Weasley
something something some of the kids I
kids obviously love you know what listen
to your parents and do good in school so
how do you think they're undermining
like what is it about their message
that's undermining like the system's
ability to raise kids or teach kids like
what are they telling them I personally
really believe that the way it comes
across to me as I am an American and I
live in Seattle it's like I don't want I
don't want to admit I'm an American in
Seattle because that's that's like
almost become the hate to say hi I'm an
American
I mean I've I love my country Houston
you love your country all you must love
Donald Trump then well Trump wasn't even
in office when I got the shenanigans
with the social gesture lawyer I mean he
had nothing to do with it yeah it was
but that's the thing that's a scary part
of some of the the message that is being
sent out and I appreciate immigration
coming into the country but there's a
right way and there's a wrong way and
many of my peers and associates always
go through the pro have gone through the
process to become American citizens
are from Yemen or from Mexico or from
Canada or overseas I mean it's just
there's the right way in a wrong way and
but it's this idea that you can't you
can't like it is something to that where
it's like you can't be proud not proud
but like like you said you can't be like
I'm an American I'm just like a dude I'm
just I'm a sis male I missus white male
my mom put a flag up on this past
holiday and I think there was one other
one at the end of the block and she goes
you know we used to have flags up and
down our street all the time American
flags as so that's another thing that is
oh did you see who put a flag up in
front of their yard it's unreal yeah and
it's like it's become in Seattle it
really is crazy anybody that says it's
not true many of us know it is true and
and and you definitely do not say you're
Republican and Cl because that is just
get your head cut all that is that is
the hate that's even worse that's a hate
of all I also feel like I'm not a
Republican but I feel like the dialogue
today I think it probably was really
embodied where you're coming from of
this like this team mentality of like
either you're with us or you're against
us and there's no likely but yeah like
this this symbol of like you and xarna
like you both kind of agreed in the
middle somewhere but there was no
understanding there was no effort to
like meet that can find that
compromising I feel like on the lesson
on the right both both parties are are
just absolutely off the edge and what I
made clear is I supported the pregnant
women and recovery programs like a
Ballard Swedish that helps women get off
opiates and and drugs and alcohol so
that they have a clean childbirth and
and I go every week to a couple of
different meetings where there's
pregnant women and we built this
camaraderie I bella camaraderie with the
moon
and and I come across as a dirtbag male
adilyn your dad fainted yeah it's all
but I read what I do work what I do not
do what I will not do is get involved
with those pregnant women's lives and
become dad I'd know better
I'm grandpa now you know you drop the
kid off okay come pick him up that's you
know it's like dogs sitting right not
all we're not not like dogs sitting but
I my Duchess I'm gonna [ __ ] sue I've
taken care of for the past seven years
and it's been it's been my anti
pregnancy tool because if I can't take
care of a dog how am I going to take
care of a child and so that's been my
resistance to having more children so
even if I can't alive yeah so that's
been good but though it's really that
women in that are homeless with children
support that there's seniors and a
variety of different other services and
programs mental health services she
can't come after me unless she knows me
if I did something that was hatred
towards somebody call me out on it but
don't judge me before you get to know me
right cuz
the way I look or the way I speak well
yeah she and I kind of your white I know
everything about you and no way you know
public schools educated don't blame me
don't blame the whites blame your school
system because I'm smart because I can
breed I can math and I can get a honey
gardening that LM really you know what I
mean really seriously I mean I cannot
without Zarda actually was kind of a
gift from God because I mean humongous
yeah well mean what is a humongous I
mean humongous changed the word
humongous to to this I mean you wanna
meet my changed you manga so she just by
the fact she put on that Facebook and
thought I'd called me the villain and it
has been used
for bullion in Seattle Public Schools in
some of our really oh yeah anti-bullying
think even beyond the politics of it is
just like the best Justice Boehner ever
which everybody loves just seeing like
justice come and I think that this whole
the whole saga of her trying to pay you
as a villain then somebody stealing it
and putting it on YouTube every one
being like no [ __ ] you
your whole story of like how you how
everything's worked out for you as a
result it's just like a fairy tale
humungous fairy tale needs to be a kids
book you're an sjw landmine there's btq
absolutely this didn't work out it is
like Harry Potter comes back you're the
one that survived
all right four miles away from the Harry
Potter Park Harry Potter Universal yeah
it's pretty close do you want to go
there yeah I think um I want to go there
are you fan of Harry Potter no but I
mean I could magically you know I mean
hey maybe I can be a character and I
could be a you know anything I've been
there's really whoever's listening to
this podcast I'll be a character let's
work it let's work a deal go through
Ethan laughs those are wizardry if you
go through h3 that's the agent so guys
yeah we are looking to cast Rudy and the
next Harry Potter prequel called the
amazing journey of humongous the one who
survived got hit me up University
alright let's let's do this is the
longest playthrough of all time or hey
she is a Hispanic Latino Chicano we're
proud of our heritage your time I want
to say this right now I respect you when
you see
hey QB can you tell me or the Garrity
what happened yeah how was that noise
originated from a human what that was
that look is a big log and you that's
what what sort of God did you see this
sound originated from a person because
I'm curious what little bit somebody in
the back and the very far white what is
it is the notion for day like gagging
and coughing what even enjoyed that it
was a it was it was a I forgot it was
oral but it is squeal and that's what
they do with those council chambers I'm
not surprised I mean all tell there's a
now there's no way there's no English
anymore it's like going to squeals let's
see when I went and watched Purple Rain
concert what's his name Prince Prince I
would saw Prince back in Seattle back in
the days and I took my girlfriend and
I'm sitting there and there must have
been a Ksenia number of screaming girls
right in my ear and I could barely hear
Prince because these little girls were
screaming at him right and I'm gone
Scotty and I can - that's what that
screeches it's all this memory it might
have been a guy but it wasn't it was I
think it might have been a female who's
a female social justice or mating call
but though if you've not done for me as
long as you would not have evolved
nothing will you know sir the call well
usual you could have made known your
intentions to me by going back and then
you guys would add then you'd have more
babies on Dutchess don't worry my Shih
Tzu so now you got he's coming home you
know how to respond next time yeah well
give them room right back you look like
you're on the verge of laughing and like
a mix of laughter and disbelief it's a
couple more second to wrap up good
that's what I asked her what why not
only a couple more seconds you this
answer has to answer the other day in
West Seattle you
a forum the kid the woman that is the
chair and I was talking was talking on
the far right side okay got it
I just don't have time to talk to you
right now Rudy you were being rude you
were trying to talk I don't have time
and then her campaign manager says oh
I'm sorry
better luck next time Wow then I go holy
[ __ ] I mean better luck that's all right
I got walk it down and they're talking
about racial diversity racial justice
but somehow really from our just does
not get that grid
they wanted a they just they didn't want
that to be happen no they really did
open up a can of worms for that council
and I really do seriously we're going to
more of it so anybody that has ideas
about comical type relief programmers
you can definitely go to Seattle City
Council Chambers and get some good
material fresh memes you don't need to
just focus on Trump you can focus on our
CL City can okay good to know
you know I we make a fair and balanced
I'd say people getting pissed off that
easily definitely good for comedians
know that a good person gets caught in
the crossfire but it would have to
happen outside of Seattle because it
would have it because in Seattle they're
afraid because we're snowflakes my god
gentrify a neighborhood in Seattle I
think it's a fine neighborhood just like
gender [ __ ] just get like a bunch of
like a fresh over the border like meadow
and here now that all the coffee shop by
it's just by a huge property they're
going to make them all live there let
people put parking cones down to save
spots again millions of dollars in
identifying it let's watch this sugar
Commons open I'm trying to see on timing
wait what I have to say doesn't matter
because I live in a be utterly seriously
what matters is
is is what everybody else has to say we
support this precinct we think it's
important investment for Public Safety
in the North End so here's what I'm
really curious about like clearly some
[ __ ] happen that you were in disbelief
about like what happened there there
were so many comments we made to me you
know in a shotgun fashion that I thought
I was trying to block it out before not
talking just a smack talk okay and I'm
in no kinetic a column madam chair just
had lost all control of that hearing and
and pretty much channeled me out by
cutting me off and I given me additional
time and the stuff I wanted to say I
wasn't able to say in that the Seattle
Police in Snohomish County Sheriff's
Department and that hopes soldiers that
was truly grateful was the thing that
helped me with my adult daughter and
going to the City Council in the past in
the mayor's office they didn't care they
say well really good knock in I'll say a
prayer for you but you've got a daddy
call I can't let it go is there a
cartoon but a gold snow let us know let
us know let us know so Blake let us know
I said [ __ ] that
I mean forget that noise forget that
noise and so it really energized me to
go after and try to do it on my own and
you know being a gardener there's not a
high celebrity status but I didn't care
I'm going to get I'm on it I'm going to
do everything I can I actually got sober
a month before this hearing it was a
little over a month before to go find my
daughter and work with the system and go
through the process to help me get her
off the streets and that I was able to
do that and then the right thing to do
was to go to the City Council that helps
decide the funding for our communities
is to say
make the officers the men and women in
uniform for helping our family and
that's all I went for I didn't go to
hack on social justice or black lies
black lives matter had nothing to do
with me in fact when I was walking out
through her a few african-american guys
that came up said would you say direct
toward my news team let's go oh what a
joke you know what I mean I'm going to
I'm gonna get this Saturday I go I got
it I got to get out of here and I said
I've met you guys I'm about in here I
just need to get to that stairway and
get to the rail get downstairs I get
downstairs I get to the bus and it's on
CBS radio I don't know if you knew this
I don't know if you can get the footage
of this Dorie Monson a Cairo news radio
had the audio that day while I was on
the bus heading back to my truck and who
you were listening back to it on the
radio I would I know I was if my
neighbors had come up to me and said you
know I heard you on Cairo during Monson
show and they said of this converse of
this conversation right of the other one
at the original video regard oh I'm
going what I'm I was and I was on the
bus going what the hell just happened
there you know I'm on the bus and I get
back to Ballard and the next thing is
have you seen your video and so I really
be D Utley it was on it would there was
a video being shown on social media or
something right
and it was already on the radio I think
maybe by one o'clock in the afternoon I
think I'm on the left at 12:30 so it was
on the radio at 1:00 that quick I didn't
know anything about it till a few days
later how did he get there so I have no
idea because I crazy it was it was it
was the craziest thing and when the
neighbor says you know Rudy couldn't she
give him her a different name I said
yeah if I were to give under my name you
know what just showed up to your house
bah
we would want that room he didn't have
said of course not do you think I'm
stupid and so I yeah it was pretty wild
it was thank God for the garden because
I was my balance because everything was
hitting me I want Santa's garden pan
Toya's garden and I gotta say you must
be the most famous gardener in the world
now
well I'm like you know I roll down the
truck Duchess hanging out the other side
the Shih Tzu that's it
heavy metal rock and roll you know
grandpa Rudy Gannon and then then Anna
the United to get out of my truck with
my new hip fat as heck see what hurts
first okay grab the weed eater but what
I did do this week is I backed off of
the dusty garden to save my pipes for
this podcast cuz I could Rex already see
it already coming here Oh Chuck Oh
moderation in the jet stream
oh he took a couple days off gardening
yeah I took a savory
claritin nice while you and I miss my
ear plugs on the airplane and my ear
plugs to protect my ears that's also
that I come in here and I gotta hide
Rico sounds beautiful man beautiful you
look beautiful your kawaii next I think
we should take a let's take a short
break if you need to run to the bathroom
or something I'm going to thank our
sponsors yeah I'm gonna call Ron Howard
real quick and fifty I do that life
story Cat Stevens Gilbert on Howard we
meet would maybe Rudy Pachulia in the
gut in the Goblet at Univision hey get
those monkey hey hey we can do the the
what do you call the the bird they show
of the word switch from English to
Spanish the subtitles captions captions
yeah I can do your division yeah you
want to execute your head we're getting
in the bottom of the screen like ah and
we you're like a little figure that
stands on the bottom now wait you're
bigger than that we need to get your
Harry Potter the gobble of notice yeah
you let a bunch of little paint loose
yet yeah we're gonna get you the data
you already there but do it alright so
I'm going to thank our sponsors you want
some water a coffee here we go the
bathroom grade okay cool so my friend
today's show is brought to you by Rick
and Morty yeah how crazy is that what's
that Rick and Morty is Adult Swim newest
and acclaimed season of an excellent
cartoon I feel like everybody must know
Rick amore by this point I almost feel
silly even reading the description it's
like so prolific yeah it's completely
infiltrated like every step of our
culture I feel like by incidentally
created by one of our one of our best
friends Justin roiland
you guys haven't seen Rick and Morty
it's one of my favorite personal
favorite trails I think everybody I
talked to it is a cartoon about a
sociopathic genius scientist Rick and is
less intelligent grandson Morty that's
really good that's the full [ __ ]
description I mean an app tell you stuff
you can't really say more about it it
are like a it's like this crazy mix of I
would say like dr. hazel and Ren and
Stimpy
that's yeah yeah it's just it's a total
space romp it's it's amazing and the new
season is coming out at long last July
30th at 11:30 this Sunday this Sunday my
friends we should watch the trailer yes
watch it live don't do the TiVo slide on
by the idea we're talking about on day
let me show you here let me show you
what I'm talking about because of it on
before there has been - there's been two
seasons it was like the one of the most
popular shows on television past two
years if you go to IMDB it's like number
three or something top rated TV shows
does their sound
how can the sound always doesn't work is
this sound on my page Morty Rick where
are you on my workbench Morty are you
invisible and you're gonna like fart on
me put the pickle over I turned myself
into a pickle Maury a pickle ran
and conquer yo you probably have all
seen the show and if you have it put on
your friggin TV set on July 30th at
11:30 get your sweet ass over to Adult
Swim and put that [ __ ] on the drama all
I can say is pickle rick yeah watch out
for particular rick that [ __ ] is going
to blow your way so thank you to Adult
Swim and Rick amore for supporting the
show appreciate you next up naturebox
god naturebox gets me so amped these
guys have have you tried the nature buck
I haven't known next time next time
you're here we're going to naturebox
really what is live April they have a
they have snacks that you order online
they're fresh
it's healthy and let me tell you it's
delicious it's really that they've got
these hundreds of snacks that taste
great and are better for you high
quality simple ingredients which means
no artificial colors flavors or
sweeteners so you feel good about what
you're eating your many candidates okay
well here you listen good head on over
to nature box calm
you get three free snacks okay think
about that I recommend the sriracha
cashews I'm still dreaming about the
sriracha cashews that we had last time
things are insane check out the sriracha
cashews check out the cheddar lentil
loops those ones were pretty spicy and
hot but there's hundreds of them and
they all look amazing I freaking love it
I wish we had some on the table right
now I'd be eating them I did something
right along the way there's some on the
way I can't I'm just going to sit
patiently office and wait for those to
arrive but uh if you don't like the
snacks you don't have to eat them you
try it if you don't like it you send it
back it's free you guys they replace it
with some new snacks but these sriracha
roasted cashews I'll be laying in bed
with you at night I'll wake her up is-3
Emily teach are they cashews on the way
are the stretch it catches really is
like [ __ ] leave me alone dude I'm
gonna sleep she goes back to been a
shaker again I'm like yo it's amazing I
I'm upset
try those cashews and tell me they
aren't amazing we go to nature bodies
Kozue naturebox calm and get free three
three three free snacks with their first
order guys it's a no risks proposition
and I'll tell you what they support our
show and I appreciate them if you're in
the market for some snacks consider
going there and picking them up just
help support the show get some BOM
snacks they get reporting Adult Swim
sponsoring this episode we'll take a
quick coffee break quick urination break
and we will be back you won't want to
leave guys because up next we have
Erik's conspiracy corner and after that
we have dance
send me the nudes Shan Shan is a new
year that I named we've given a 10
degrees so guys thanks for hanging out
we'll be right back in a short short
brief break if you leave something
terrible is going to happen I know it's
true don't welcome back to the h3
podcast here with your boy Rudy pentaiah
jr. aka humongous we have on deck Eric's
conspiracy closet the big big debut of
our new segment by our wonderful friend
here they're making signals don't mind
yeah but first I wanted to ask you
really a couple more questions something
that fascinates me you were you were a
character in Seattle but now you're kind
of like a celebrity in a way like you
were telling me you were at a coffee
shop before you came here people note
recognized you and you mentioned to me
that even in Seattle and people are
saying hi to you everyday like how
famous are you how often are you being
recognized it's amazing I just they know
the truck really oh yeah they know the
truck they see the truck hey there's
they up and tracked to the u-turn follow
me hey hey hey you can picture with you
come on boys come on again and then
there's you know then there's the moms
that want the family portraits really
well they pull the kids and I'm with the
mom and the last somebody take a picture
look I got I got a picture with you -
honey I gotta you might think how is
that was I just well it's like overnight
like
well Amos guy I just went with it I
rolled with it I just didn't question it
it was something that I had to learn I
learned because it to become a humungous
you just don't become humongous so it's
like saying I'm going to be a golfer I'm
going to go buy the new set of golf
clubs now I'm going to be a part golfer
that doesn't work that way it takes time
so I had to sit back and learn it in and
I wasn't something I created was created
by your audience in your audience to
find what humongous was based on my past
being a gardener and strength in you in
any way no absolutely not I can just go
out there in garden and and let
humongous the character be the character
that the gardener is could they kind of
feed off of one another
and it's like the world or the country
people saw this guy Rudy from Mallard
the gardener that they could relate to
and it became a worldwide thing and you
enjoy getting recognizing it doesn't
bother me at all I guess I just roll you
know I just and it doesn't bother me in
any way other than you know there's
times I have to say no really I mean I
was doing the film with Richard but the
kids from bel-air hi I'm acting going
through the Pike Place Market and people
were kinda haters humungous a home I
made actually and they've got the camera
on me and hey hey come on it's gonna be
a picture with you I'm doing a movie you
know and so I gotta move out and
unbelievable and I'll get people that
will be stopped mom gardening get out of
their car want a picture I go into
churches the kids run out to me thank
you
same I get it are you ever popular in
the gardener now well I really good you
know what you know I I don't need more
clients I tell you that I the body in my
hip can only do so much
and I've learned to take this 53 year
old body and plan to have it at six
three because I'm a I'm not jumping off
the tailgate of the track we're jumping
up robberies I'll kind of waddle down
the rockery waddle off the truck right
you know because we will wobble but they
don't fall down
we don't something like that you should
outsource you guys get some workers for
Pentos garden I plan on doing that I
it's a the goal was is to hold on to
what I have and you all helped me keep
what I have and now this next phase is
to take what I have and transform it on
to something more for the garden and
what and and number one is my health my
health is the goal fund helped me a lot
during the hard times of being able to
get through the medical procedures and
and allow my hip to heal and that Johnny
bad grass to the gardener can get out
there and kick some serious grass and
take some serious receivable if you know
you care you know that's that's a softer
gentler Rudy for valor way of expressing
himself because you know it's try to
keep it PG I think the thing that packs
me up is these knuckleheads that take my
face and put it on Facebook and they
turn it into a porn site or oh yeah it's
been all my errand and not really a job
working and I'm going I'm going I was
really I wouldn't of all the celebrities
I've ever seen like make born of your I
got a note but it's not me I mean it's
it's my they use the Facebook yeah to
draw people in and then to get the same
training form it into a porn set yeah I
can't have I can't see you getting
railed necessarily I'm not uh no there's
no way I'm gonna be a porn no not
usually no absolutely no heck no
no no what forget a GoFundMe going no
not even not even his aren't I wait you
and Zara how much money you don't hate
that's a good one hey gender the gender
sensei and I said gender such a Mack
McGregor the one that was running that
came out when I first filed for sale
City Council I go to the other day I
said hey Mack what if we did like a
sparring moment where we give any suits
and do something for charity he says you
know I think about that I think about
that and he says you should tell your
guy up to down there you know your guy
which would be you either I'm the guy I
said cuz you know karate and I know
karate and you know we're not into
kicking each other's butt other than not
come in last place in this campaign you
know might go and he says I think you
know what I think that's a good idea
you know what so Mac if you're listening
let's plan a sparring moment for charity
you and xarna xarna could be the breath
i wonder who would wind i think he would
win I gotta figure out a way to get her
down there like we'll give this amount
of money to some organization she
supports put her in a place where if she
says no she's a racist okay
tell me tell me about your house yeah
that works
how's your helping because I know you
had a health scare when that whole thing
went down I'm really curious how you
been well I was I was told to when I was
going to Cancer Care Alliance they
checked out the group was able to remove
some cysts from my body that words
benign and that I have a swollen spleen
think of and the and that I had been
poked by a couple of syringes in the
past they assumed that maybe hepatitis C
that was dormant had come back up hoped
oh yeah I was out gardening and I was
hit by dirty apparently me hat [ __ ]
isn't it all that matter that's not and
that was part of the the process of why
I was going through being checked out
for my platelet
for being down low so I the doctor says
to me he says you know I going to need
you to not drink we're going to try to
see if you're passed drinking has caused
any sort of hardship on your organs I
said well I've been sober a couple of
months why you have he says I'm reading
a book and it's about social drinkers do
usually make her ask me a few questions
about social being a social drinker and
a drinker and he says you know you're
not a social drinker right forgot that
so he sounds he's got some glasses day
of you know finally Impressionist and I
said oh yeah I know he says well don't
you think once we find out what to let
the pint went said you maybe not drink
it might be a good idea so from here on
out till we figure out what's wrong with
you
I'm going to need you to like this not
drink like oh okay doctor and if you
drink then you're just wasting my time
so I've been sober a year yes
and when I went when I went to that
council meeting I already I was sober
right and I didn't go in there to be a
jackass or Beavis Butthead I went in
there can't no support my daughter and
and girls like her it's not just her but
across the board and but the fame is
tell the kids I tell the cared with the
kids kids I'm a gardener I'm a schmuck
in the truck and I only encourage you
kids to get an education be the best you
can be and miss your parents listen your
teachers and as long as you can read and
you can do as long as you can read you
could do the math the science and
everything else and then you can get a
job from money to get the honey get the
iodine I guess go that's are humongous
yeah baby is social move you know
now you can vote for him he's running
out City Council and the phenomenon
continues to spread across the world if
there's anybody listening out there
especially the young voters 18 and over
make a homemade sign and flash a full
perk you is a vote for you position 8
Seattle City Council my vote so I'm here
in LA and I will be back until Monday
and the election is Tuesday so oh wow
Tuesday guys get up here and campaign
yes I like your mug it is on how to vote
illegally is about family bonding what
are the odds can I hope you know what we
probably shouldn't say that right yeah
yeah yeah I think they did that in the
old days cuz I might output here I just
want to do that no absolutely not apples
in a hour William gale like camera
less like houses people over just
between you and I is you know they think
you know new pencil Pharisee do you
think you have a chance of winning I
think what I've done is I've opened up
the opportunity for others in the future
just anybody because that humongous can
do it anybody can do it I said in and
the thing is the bottom line is if you
don't boat
you can't [ __ ] and you don't get the
high ed oh yeah there's no debating you
know we just depended after this
campaign we'll see what happens with at
least on this point is that this it's
really important that people exercise
their opportunity and not let people who
are radical whether they're on the left
or the right to shut you down
yeah need to get but it needs to happen
civil can't can't block in traffic
busting store windows is not the way to
go exercise the opportunity and get
like-minded people to support you and go
after it and put through the guidelines
of the law of course and but but no
violence and you don't need to say
shitty things to people because you
disagree with them there's no reason for
it and like a perfect example is the
humongous original video is
that it's a teaching moment for up for
anybody whether you're one side or the
other no reason to behave like that
absolutely so I'm god bless really
thanks for coming and sharing your story
with us I have one last question and may
it's a bit of a curveball we ask all of
our guests this I don't know why it
happened this way but our fans are
obsessed with it ghost stories do you
have any ghost stories supernatural
natural experiences in your life I had
one last night are you serious
all right here we go there's this
beautiful woman that came from the sky
and she came into Van Nuys with brown
eyes and she says qp2 Who am I kidding
I'm for real and I'm in this garden and
I'm tripping I'm in the garden let the
line between reality and dreams know
there's a dream
this is dream reality dream and so I'm
in this garden that I used to work at
and there's this woman complaining that
we cut the wrong stuff down and it's not
a band or so okay so like and and I
don't know where this place came from
and then she realized that oh the garden
is okay and I wake up and I got drool
and spit rolling out of my mouth because
I thought it was so for real okay that
was a dream but the ghost the ghost that
entered my head it goes like that cab
stuff he kind of went through and
addressed a turret and it kind of went
all over the pillow and stuff but it was
a drug for my mouth yeah it was a dream
that's a ghost story that is us the best
so who knows it could happen could that
count is a night terror we hit their
sound well er that it wonderful
it's got like a rose dressed in white
and cover down honey honey
so many inches all around Bay Bay oh my
good just inviting cover down
somebody inches all around but you -
will you be mine oh oh damn oh let's
just all these that's for the moment
that's bunk humongous mmm knock you out
that's all Josh that bong so the real
nightmare was that you had cut down the
wrong tree well yes I've done that one
that was a that's a reality house that
does a relative experienced an actor
tonight no I swear you said oh no all
righty this hottest summer digging out
that stump and replanting the tree and
other tree's beautiful though you dug up
the wrong way and then you had to
replant it replant it I cut it down
without it daddy
Rudy's guarded if we dig out the wrong
one we'll plant it right back you whoa
and it won't be under sold he won't be
undersold a new growth an opportunity
for all when it comes to the garden love
it you got my vote
thank you hey honey you got my honey you
got my room and you've got my pitch to
universal for you to be the governor of
the fungus yes I would love that I've
little Mongoose all right let's move it
on to our next report of the show today
I need to turn all blue lives matter go
Hawks
okay but that's okay there we go my
lighter in there
Thanks yeah there it is now we've got
every job so next up we are getting
ready to launch
Eric's conspiracy closet we have input
I'm sorry Dan I forgot almost everything
come help us we have a little in TOR
panicking play the intro all right so
tell them your use it okay so this is
supposed to be probably more slick than
this but it's still a podcast all right
this is a beta test to the beta the
holder is ideal for a segment full shows
a beta yes am I the one who hits this
thing do I play it in bingo okay here we
go
No buckle up buckos
and that bliss fighters it's me your boy
big conspiracy Eric I want to thank you
all for having me on the show I'm not
going to do this voice the whole time I
promise we're all fighting levels here
we got Ethan
we got ela mr. mungus pleasure to meet
you good I want to talk to you guys
about something turn off the TV [ __ ]
remote
Flattr we're gonna talk about flat earth
for a little bit and there's a lot to
talk about
are you guys familiar with Flat Earth
conspiracies at all I'm not really have
you heard of flutter three so Flat Earth
fascinates me because maybe it's one of
the more insane conspiracy theories out
there insane to the point that you can't
believe anyone could believe it
and it's always this like teetering on
the edge of are they are they all just
like really elaborate trolls yeah I
don't think they are they believe that
this surrounds the entire disk of our
earth wait what okay that actually
explains Brisby of ours that we live on
so hold on hold on that's the edge of
the earth that is the edge of the earth
what's to the left yeah
Oh to the left is earth like you'd be
sailing from Oh Australia right you go
far enough and you run into this and it
this just goes on for we got any human
has ever no one's ever seen the edge of
the earth
okay so got it so the water is the edge
of Earth this is I guess can you see the
cursor on the stream I don't know anyway
that is the ocean that we know got it
you can dip your toe in that ocean now
you go all the way to the end this
surrounds the crust of our potato chip
planet so they think that there's just
this endless void just not endless I
think it goes straight out into space
why did they do is another little
picture I found Wow so I don't know what
the [ __ ] is supposed to be but this also
has a dome in it there's a lot of little
like there's domes it domes there's a
dome what's in that I know every dome is
called the firma there's the underworld
oh yeah this is a slightly more
religious version yeah there's a lot of
atheist uh flat-earthers out there too
Rudy this is by the way that's enough
that people believe just for there's
people out there who believe that the
earth is flat and that the notion that
the world is round is a NASA conspiracy
yeah people that you might even know you
guys know Tila tequila's oh well that
does I do and that surprises a tweet
from her why are all the buildings in
NYC standing straight up if earth was
round that some of the buildings would
have a slight tilt when s how do you how
do you defend that logic flatter she's
got a point I think she does hey why
don't they have it the slight tilt well
they must they probably do have it yes
look like like lose not one that you can
perceive with your eye it's not like
they build all the buildings the same
exact height yeah so you can see the and
it simply even if you were on a a
perfect plane that they would probably
have a slight tail
yeah there's a is like a bridge I didn't
copy this down I got some notes here too
but there's a bridge where they had to
build one of the support beams like
three million dollars higher I'll make
up for the curvature of the earth and
it's not something you're really going
to see if you're looking at like a
skyline of a city possible like oh there
it is I love the logic of her yeah the
earth is she's not going dum dum ping
hon there's more good ones from her what
do you think I was I was thinking I have
a gold girl further than her house
tilted they were out to use what do you
say to hell to kill us yeah I'm teal
Odell's misses tequila
oh nice although mister okay she was
miss specifically there was Miss Pacific
oh yeah polish just to get a real idea
of like just what exactly we're up
against here in learning about this
because I want us to understand like
that's the I think the heart of what
this segment could be is that we like
understand where these people are coming
from all right you know maybe there's a
kernel of truth to this maybe there's
even though like we figured out that the
earth was round and I think 500 BC or
something like that some did with like a
stick in the desert was like did the
earth is round and tequilas like I
no I looked at some buildings in New
York they are ain't I'm not a scientist
but a tell Dean she's also not the only
one guys check this up you know there's
a flat earth society with the sale of
this tweet that says if earth was a
spinning globe and the Sun is supposedly
150 million light years away then how
come the sun rays beam straight down do
they how do we know that she's not like
the same joke and the same question
about everyone how do we know they're
not kidding well what's going to take
people seriously it's kind of a problem
in this world when you're like well
people are telling me things but how do
I know they're serious it's like how do
you live life like that well she seems
like like you say you love me are you
serious are you trolling me bro it's a
deep problem if you had as much
antipsychotic medication in her body of
Steel at the keel I would I would
brothel and she's like 30% actual person
and 70% medicine antipsychotic if the
earth was a spinning globe
then how come airplanes can still land
without crashing because the face of the
earth is flat not a globe that's what
they think is that I know I'm trying to
be defensive of them but it's it's tough
I might have picked a tough one for the
first segment but they believe they
don't believe in gravity they believe
that instead of a spinning earth which I
think has gravity to it which makes the
spinning in the gravity what not I'm
going too far into the air I don't love
the spinning is what creates gravity no
it's just the mass [ __ ] globalists
lives over here also on I don't know
that could be a lie I don't know it now
everything's in doubt like no you know
they believe the earth that there is no
gravity because if there was gravity on
a disk it would pull everything to the
center right what they believe is that
the earth is just going in really exotic
guys traveling up forever
and that's what keeps us on the [ __ ]
ground well that's how sad it was just
yeah really poke some holes in her
airplane theory though like if you were
to take off on a thing that was
constantly going up when you just
belly-flop immediately into the end of
the ground air you're supposed to defend
these people ah these are close people
these a year Peter I'm you know
he was not one of us okay she makes us
look bad she's the xarna of the of the
flat earth world you know she's on the
outskirts she's a fringe supporter now
my favorite rapper I don't know about
you guys but his b.o.b now that is a guy
I can get with I saw this developing the
cities in the background are
approximately 16 miles apart where is
the curve please explain this okay what
cities are we looking at um it's got a
lot of likes and retweets let me get in
here can i zoom this is a really
horrible picture to prove a scientific
point I feel like because I can't see
anything well they got the Sun in there
but the problem is the Sun is only 40
miles across and it's only 3000 miles
off of the ground so it can really ruin
a picture when it's traveling over you
and the clockwise motion over the disk
that we live on where's the curve please
explain this where is the curve I think
Neil deGrasse Tyson jumped in there and
like started talking to them and then
b.o.b you know I'm going to pull this up
you'll be made a rap song about it oh my
god let me do a really a grass ramp you
know what I think this is missing all
flat lines right we do not work we
didn't write until that gets poured we
live on a globe do you mind if we drink
really wide overall god Bless You Ruby
you want some coffee or something oh no
I'm gonna go out of the water here's to
our pancake how am I supposed to take
these guys seriously without a glass of
alcohol I know how many buddies supposed
to be able to take me seriously if
mm-hmm not intoxicated all right you'll
drink that drink that poison huh let's
see what we got here have you never
heard of this [ __ ] I've heard of it I
just recreated this is new isn't it I
know about ten years well the original
there's a flyer Society of Flat Earth
Society thank you so you like May they
no longer live in the shadows during the
day like okay I think by the end of this
we're all going to believe it a little
bit more despite our you know it's nice
to come in with a little bit of
apprehension where the [ __ ] is this song
here we go
and we stood there was immediate
I live on a hill how does that flat your
house if it was a globe would be coming
down the street you know yeah my best
take me in a game of chess gloves and
see me as a threat
globally sweet thing that a world of my
neck huh
and my paranoid bitchin Malcolm X in a
room full of pigs try another bun sweat
a neck sighs I need to loosen up a fence
and probably right there man when hell
of a check hey I'm over here child clown
they said I never caught him there one
coming from me and it doesn't cover
something they say that NASA must have
read Neil Tyson a hell of a chat yeah
well I mean you would think that like
we've proven that the earth is round by
going into space multiple times right
multiple countries going into space but
what really is happening is NASA is fake
they don't do anything they just
perpetuate the lie that we live on a
global what end
oh it's to make us look more powerful to
other superpowers that's such a huge can
spray no I know when I wake up - says
they've been there Russia says they've
been there they are all lying to each
other because what would happen if all
of a sudden China was like you know what
we've never been this space
all of their like you know anti-nuclear
measures and everything like that all
their satellites that they put up their
satellite becomes null it's like oh well
they got nothing with our satellite rail
yes you can you can shoot something up
there but some people will say it'll
just hit the top of the dome so
satellites aren't even necessarily real
no what's the point because we're living
on like a marble yeah
Dish Network is in bed with NASA this
does get deeper than I thought yeah you
know you have to imagine how difficult
it must be to get hundreds and thousands
hundreds of thousands of government
employees private contractors people who
just like write software for this
[ __ ] satellite - all shut up about it
like dude just take one guy on his
deathbed to be like oh by the way no
yeah no look it's black because none of
us would believe it no
that's part of why this conspiracy is so
powerful it's weird entering them if
yeah
it would be nice to get like some sort
of flat earth society perhaps oh wait
alright segue into this sounds like an
here here is like everything you need to
know to know about Flat Earth that and I
say the first question on the FAQ is
this a joke a joke let's get the answer
where is it
this site is not a joke okay
we are actively promoting the Flat Earth
movement I honestly when you guys when
we talked about this the other day I was
like it flattered it be [ __ ] funny
you know there's a couple people there I
had no idea how much of a resurgence
Flat Earth has had I think it's got to
be one of the more prolific conspiracy
theories and the weird thing is they
don't believe in other conspiracies like
they own they don't like they think
people who believe in like the
Illuminati the New World Order like
lizard people coming up from the ground
they think that stuff those guys are
saying whatever to be wasting all their
time Rudy I love your glasses will you
walk in there these are a gamer gear Dex
what is it they're prescription rudy
projects it's got your name on it it
says Rudy on it yeah the chains with a
light oh it's like they get darker when
you're well Italian italiano
but now you mean whether you can
actually change together like warm at
night oh that's really bad like when it
was raining and that there's was that
light headlights go more typica
my mama I can go mmm
right the great state is what goes on
and like we all look like weird like
globalist zombie a things they're my
safety glasses for gardening and and
combating bad cat pads yeah I got
nothing like a cap of you you look like
a real Brown derp third to me and I
don't know if I can trust you so I
barely was also this today I was got
picked up by one of those like taxi
services independent taxi
due to do humor not over this is a taxi
Oh a and I pulled in saw me and my
Seahawk in blue cap and wouldn't pick me
up because he thought I was a cop but I
like my ice I was I like even a free toy
in overtime serious I sorta got done and
so I am saying that I target sitting in
waiting and and finally this other guy
comes and picks me up and he says the
guy didn't want to pick you up because
you thought you were a cop oh yes I mean
I'm nothing to worry about and I saw
this guy laying down in the grass with
his dog I said no that would be the cop
no I'll give a cleaner yeah so it's a
little cool I mean but I'm not a cop
I'm gonna holler and say I don't know
anything anymore
this is Eric's conspiracy corner no I
thought I've already indoctrinated all
of you tonight II as skeptical
conspicuous Oriole as possible let's go
you know I'm doing I feel like we should
just hear from an actual flattered I got
that found this place article where this
guy talks about it I thought this [ __ ]
was pretty funny I just I mean this
website pretty much all I need to see
was epic you want oh there isn't there's
some stuff in that website I was at the
bar yesterday just drinking and reading
this thing for like two hours
really so this okay great agenda
projection tickets
oh god no no no these guys didn't pay us
I can't put this in our video yeah if
you already suck em you tear match a
fixed bit nuts who is going to talk over
it
co2 Toyota when I didn't say Toyota what
car was that I don't know so who cares I
can't
Oh should I hear it and we're supporting
they're going to run ten questions you
want to ask a flat earther hi I'm nice
and I'm treat I'm honest like that this
guy's got a couple of cheating loose
screws I can tell you that right now
your last company is
in my last career I was traveling around
the world as an international sales rep
and as I traveled around the world what
I observed on almost every flight was
the same thing which was lots of people
staring at the back of the headrest and
observing the latest movie owners out
drinking booze falling asleep whereas I
would actually be at the back of the
plane looking out at the emergency exit
which had the widest viewing angle and
observing the flat plane below so it is
when I saw this I chose powerline video
on YouTube and he uttered the words
flutter much in ridicule but in the same
context as we're talking about Reid I
bet he's a [ __ ] brilliant man yeah
one else was staring at the back seat he
was looking he's like look up when own
main character of his own anime well
okay although all the people are just
staring at their their People magazine
their globalist weekly right and he's
looking out the window of an airplane
unheard of I love in his fantasy world
people are literally like they're
sitting in the seats just staring at the
seat he's like what the [ __ ] wait a
second
we were totally right he's the centered
on anime really did you see that when
you're fine in while I was looking at it
the only thing I saw flat was the the
empty bottles empty plastic cup of my
water
the rest was around the earth is round
we're come on I mean I'd like ever
looked over and you can kind of see the
horizon already get it kind of rolls
just like rolling bernalillo press yeah
yeah I need to be careful what I help it
it really is beautiful yeah mother I
definitely really do believe mother
earth is a mother and child and then
somewhere along god came along and is a
dude so I mean mutters she's mother this
is you know always treat mother earth
with care sensitivity compassion her
love nothing like the garden love yeah
you need to have that idea about it to
make a garden you'll be kids Laura she I
feel like I'm at my donor to the earth
because I watch things grow every day
seeing if the earth was flat than
I think the idea is that the having a
sphere earth makes us so not special
this guy says something like that at the
end let me hear this guy I love this guy
already immediately was a Eureka moment
I mean I literally went and woke my wife
open Solander the excess glass are you
guys still together
No Patel Conover never were developing a
sole purpose of lying to us their only
purpose is to perpetuate right there
lonely Brutus everything Lorelai all by
NASA has the sub contacts in anything on
a globe way they're faking things is
with top of the line absolutely
cutting-edge studio techniques like
we're used in some gravity so they using
trapeze they're on high wires gravity a
film from 2015 missing
they've been faking the moon were there
or the Earth's hold the earth the globe
conspiracy for a minute yeah see if I
can get to a part where this guy really
starts to shine which we need Sasquatch
to come snag um I believe in a sasquatch
preferably without much we ran out of
flat things food compared to I love that
the interviewers I could do it all only
meet you and like a wide open public
place like well he probably chose the
Vista behind him because of how flat it
looks like where's the curve there look
at the distance between those those
buildings why isn't it look like a
fisheye effect or Indianapolis is flat
Kansas is flat flat face the ends of
their so it's a difficult one to give
you an answer that's that's the other
thing they is the moon a nice no but
does the moon have fake news surrounding
it yes absolutely of all of the
celestial bodies it's the one that would
most indicate sort of forces is always
being spherical and then for it's used
by people like nesters to prop up a
notion that we are live living on a
sphere also so like that used to
perpetuate a views
the music do I get ridiculed now no
doesn't seem to be the case for years on
now it's more like a people actually
wanting to know more information about
the subject and doing the research
themselves so I think as we've
accumulated progress may plug it yeah
they do something with his voice or do
people take you seriously absolutely
within your game we're standing on a
giant flat Ridge absolutely no one says
anything to my face that denigrates me
in any way all I don't have an actual
explanation for how things work I don't
know I don't I have no explanation this
is beyond all of us that's a pretty
common thing with the flat earthers the
one they can't answer about the season
there's so many things that that they're
just like oh we don't know a lot of it
is off of like what you can observe with
your own eyes so they'll say you know I
haven't seen I haven't been to the Sun
to like scoop up a little bit of its Sun
jelly right and test it to see if it's
like as big as we say it is there as far
away we're real not made of cheese could
even just be not real moons the same way
they believe that the Sun and the moon
are opposite each other on the flat
earth and they just go like on our Flat
Earth they're like right above it it's
the Sun is not as big as it is a sphere
or is it also flat it's also sphere I
mean it is a sphere oh so where our
planet is the only flat one yeah the
ones around that's what makes us special
that's logically makes sense there's
other people who say that like you know
we haven't seen it so how would we know
which is why are they making assumptions
about the Sun and Moon being round and
they haven't been there yeah well I
think it's because they don't see a
curve but have they seen the edge of the
or you know that picture supposed to be
ledge apparently if you try to go to the
edge of those government agents waiting
for a boat yeah if you try to fly a
drone I know we're like wouldn't it be
cool to let everybody know that we live
on a flat earth just would that be great
I would tell everyone it's such an
incredible coverup and conspiracy and I
mean there hasn't always been government
agencies to protect the border of a flat
earth yeahi we have the man
or for that like why don't one of these
guys get in a [ __ ] boat and go
sailing
I think they've tried there's okay good
thank you
I need we need a Christopher Columbus he
was the first clatter but it was a lay
person we in the Nordic neighborhood I
live in they are tough when it comes to
late very soon and Christopher Colombo
oh yeah I know he gets yellow Columbus
gets all that Columbus was actually he
was the first flat earther he was trying
to prove there at this flat but they've
rewritten history to make it seem like
he thought it was a globe and it's just
a total globalist conspicuous yeah its
total fake that's some globular [ __ ]
right there that's for one so that's not
it I didn't make that term up by the way
that's really what they call people who
believe that we live on a globe globe is
what you list it's like being a
globalist who believes live on a globe
you [ __ ] blows over the game and I
saw that word really down I was like
this is going to take a second lecture
hundred by people in a bar like quote me
will this globe you and I just a globe a
globe it's a Glovis twould be better but
they want to make it sound like
globalist globe you-let's globalist so
this is it this is the enemy well we are
we are the enemy I think well you guys
are the enemy I'm like a Jack O'Lantern
stole jury's out on me you're wearing
the flattered I am wearing the Flat
Earth shirt I'm not making money off
that at all are these people going to
come to my house and attempt to murder
on my life well now we call okay good
no no they don't have the Internet
they're my enemy that you receive a flat
pumpkin that's like this part of a good
joke
imagine thumpkin Wow water is always
stationery airplanes when they go to the
cruising altitude they find stationery
why these flat earthers are always just
like the simplest they always have a
little bit of a screw loose and they all
their observations and they're like
irrefutable theories are based on I was
on a plane once and I looked out and it
looks flat yeah they don't take any
facts that come from anybody else is one
of the problems with there
line of reason had all based on seeing
as believe all based on seeing it's I I
can see no curve and one of the first
like resurgence is in Flat Earth like
after Christopher Columbus and Magellan
and all those guys was we know the earth
was [ __ ] around we ancient Greece
rather the shadows in the way that they
curved
yeah but there was like in the early
1800s to this guys Samuel rowboat ham
sickest sound yeah there's a little buzz
I think into one of these I think we
from the audio jack look out god damn
[ __ ] global is trying to show go
ahead they can't get us surrounded by
tinfoil never really what you guys want
wrap it up
guess they try to get in your head is
gone you need a lot of tinfoil for that
did you hear that now in the cafeteria
yeah
their cabins so let me tell you about
Samuel rowboat ham he conducted an
experiment fun on the can you bring in
some tape you guys ever heard of the Old
Bedford River in Norfolk England no
alright well exhausted it's a six mile
stretch of river right
so naturally the Earth's curve would
affect the height of the water yeah
right and so what he did was observed
the ship with a tall mast going down the
river for the six miles and they didn't
see the the masts go down you know
logically if we lived on a flat earth
you wouldn't see the mass go down and
you didn't see the mass go down so we
live on a flat earth they have done that
same experiment multiple times since
then and I always add the same results
just on that one little River but that's
the river to go to if you want to prove
that the earth is flat so on this
particular the Bedford level experiment
educators on your head I can't hear you
it's only in your head
that could be a good satellite to hit in
your head you know you got to cover up
you look like a gang you look like the
you look like the Pope who [ __ ] lost
it all wraps we got to get really
wrapped in a hold on Eric just we're way
too dangerous to continue without we got
to get to make sure varieties promised
cueing some good stuff up and yeah we're
going from band alive in the middle of
this segment baby in there
I am tinfoil rudia 10:00 at night
today's dude Christ save me from your
evil attack you've already been infected
I need some Rose a really good yeah to
be a good addition to thank you this is
not a good summer look by the way this
is really I feel like this'll cook you
make you like a baked potato I like my
baked potato look Rudy's making it
fashionable by putting his hat on top
right protected you know it's in that
hat there could be microchips in that
hat it's got Seahawks Super Bowl
Seahawks are taking it this year boys
you heard it from Rudy big work you're
such a globalist I'm tired of these
global you ideal guys live IG Hawks when
there's you know when I come home from a
hard day of fighting the globalist you
know what I like to do is I like to tune
in to the 24/7 live YouTube Flat Earth
channel oh why what globalists have shut
us down well alright nice try globalist
I recorded a little bit of this earlier
why don't we play some of that Liberty
this was up this was up when we checked
it earlier today right morning yeah yeah
I'm telling you we're on to something
here I mean it was either the globalist
or the or the license holder of the
people who shoot it so now that doesn't
make sense might be a full of oil show
you guys are way high light so this is
the 24/7 flat earth live hundred percent
proof NASA lies and Earth is not a
not flattered of society I'm not sure
well not flattered society's I don't
know if that's a different society that
later on I'm flattered
it's just they're trying to say what it
is not yet what's going on with them is
there is they trying to show you they're
not flattered society maybe they're the
dome believers are they at odds the
other different sects oh there's
definitely people what we saw the
religious thing earlier where like
there's people who don't believe in the
underworld part of it cuz I to imagine
living down the word yeah I'm all about
thunder I believe in the underwear but
not the dome it's you could do it ala
carte you know make like a little bit of
a little bit I'm you know bleed of that
dome I believe there's more outside the
ice I believe is a whole nother and we
and the globe camperos taller more
majestic you think there's more flat
earths beyond i yeah definitely we've
never put in battle aid out there how
would we know there's somebody
controlling us
I'm starting to realize it more than
olive oil is not protected enough well
if you were to go to the 24/7 500 500
percent proof NASA lies on earth it's
not a globe not flatter a society thing
when it was up you'd see something like
this much courage till they are hurling
through space on a molten rock at 67,000
miles an hour and the only thing that
keeps them from flying out of their
shoes is their misplaced faith and
gravity misplaced faith nominee wrong
[Music]
wait it's not done like a headache we
would have made three years ago
look woman yep yep they got them because
there is the law such as gravity we can
and will create itself from nothing now
say thank you cash that was just made by
Stinky's - eternal of love I got it my
god this is a two-minute clip by the way
always amazing next good uh it might be
something like that in the Flat Earth
community which is I can't put this on
[ __ ] channel this is good um gravity
is your God you just figured it out
gravity is your God they know that
that's just like a sitcom right well not
when Holly was run by the globalist
agenda this is a joke what this yeah
this clip has to be a joke now watch
it's not a joke look at this way that is
so active mm-hmm wait for it Rebbe does
not evil God okay
[Music]
have I convinced you guys yet I don't I
feel like we're getting close to it yeah
all right here's another example of the
earth being flat vice land put a joint
into space but what really gives it away
is the insane amount of curvature at the
very beginning of the video while the
camera both still cliff a shiloh now if
you were to unfished I that die be a
flat ass earth right so I guess they are
saying that we can put stuff into space
wait what are they saying yeah I don't
know they say well you have been a trace
so they're saying these guys sent a
camera into space look how they
obviously fake the curvature of it yeah
and then I wish I lens well why would
Vice Lian being on that aren't they all
about likes crown it's all the way up
down dancer [ __ ] globalist man they're
everywhere
you guys want to see a flat earth rap
video real dumb dumb I want to see this
guy with his okay I got to go to second
though somehow these guys are all
harvard-educated it breaks them in
there's a lot of pressure
I'm going to League school the chest
depositor was coming out about all the
celebrities Shaq yeah this was the
English guy this is an apt Angelyn guy
he didn't know Edgar was called that's
that same guy yo that's Annette no way
is a video that guy getting trigger in
Starbucks yeah he saw an ass actually I
gave you a flippin I'm never in a minute
yeah that's him he freaks out and she
gave him a sorta clear and he didn't
know it was called a snicker he called
it and with an emblem on the chat is
saying that you should call Joey solids
that's it that's where their mind is ask
him about letters yeah what yeah about
what
and by filers well we could convince I
don't think ol Joey right if Joey comes
out in support of Flat Earth um I don't
see that it's gonna be a short call he's
like in the background in one of these
videos um okay I forget I take this
officer I wouldn't listen I just pulled
it up tomorrow
yeah I'm getting cooked
Thompson believe he's been targeted for
his beliefs I really think I got
crosshairs on my back
CIA the FBI is this the same guy is this
the same guy to you that is that's the
weirdest Starbucks guy oh this parts
great it was actual there in the middle
of [ __ ] Venice Beach right
I don't know whines I like the music
so the waving of the hands you can tell
just how much this guy's trying to get
through to him what was that
conversation you're going to talk about
with the globe oh one sec he he does a
little science experiment for him I
don't know if you need rally literally
takes a frisbee take this and put it
right here right go around it like this
okay that means the Sun wouldn't rise
and fall in the east to the west as it
does it would literally go out and it
would be great guys it might be oh my
god pay attention ahead it does it kind
of does
they started out with 911 they started
out with vaccines they started out with
chemtrails or something I mean word I'm
with them I don't know this has been a
wild ride talk to me and do it I'm in
and uh this guy strapped video it up for
the rapid yet I mean I'm sure I would be
for the rap video but Mother Earth
Mother Earth you cannot to be very -
yeah you know it has to be there's I
mean I just flew and looked outside the
windows and I can tell it was round well
because I'd like to see Frank I looked
at the back of the seat and I proceeded
I looked all around and and it round the
promit that is planes windows are curved
so it's it's changing how you see the
horizon what you see is a refraction of
light through get out III I know that
when I use the black screen is one all
right all right we're let's exit the
closet yeah I get I'm in I'm sold the
earth is flat
I need a fedora I need a chinstrap shave
and I need some clipping NASA emblems
gone how could you - actually how does
it look
it feels like it looks great oh by the
way thank my dad for that uh that
interim yeah you shot that yes Holly hi
you know tell he look like a jolly pop
after being shut up off board the sky
hot dad yeah made that theme song in a
frickin second dude I know I asked him
about it and he was like oh I already
have this that's not how I work oh but
we'll link in the description it's
flatter than interesting conspiracy like
almost not it's almost not so obscene
that one of the things I realized when I
was looking at ate all of this stuff I
was telling you earlier I was like you
know I was looking at the flatter stuff
and a lot of it is like people just
doing dumb mass like if you try to get a
funny video of somebody talking about
Flat Earth it's going to be like a weird
montage of like lizard people images and
like the diagrams that they've made in
like like Photoshop or like yours though
here's the way the light the Sun shoots
light out with like weird little
mathematical angles and stuff it's so
boring and dumb I think next time I do
this I'm going to talk to you guys about
like lizard people I want to know
something interested Cantrell's I like I
got ya I'm not in deep on chemtrails
something about that there's chemicals
in the air that turns the frogs gay
right okay Alex germs
yeah Sencha Lee do you know about
chemtrails ooh it turns the frogs gay
mmm well hermaphroditic it makes them
it's one of those things that make you
go hmm yeah really okay mm-hmm
convective as much of a response Isis
thanks for sharing talk to you later
well thanks for stepping into the cloud
well thank you that was great yeah
stepping in the closet and I'm flicker
stepping out
beta test step in step out I was in the
closet known out of the closet a lot
more materials that I can show you guys
after the show if you want there's like
there's no lack of I want to carry on
personally okay
I'm not some posts alright well I hope
you guys enjoyed that they didn't was
Creek it was a weird wild ride yeah I
think the flat the flat earthers are
just flat others are there the island
yeah they're just a little bit flat
grained notify their own opinion you
know hey get original get ups your own
opinion you're so PC really I'm glad
he's a politician now I know can't till
August 3rd then the gardener's back then
the garnish bears off a lot of others I
can either negative political ads now of
like you with the tinfoil hat on and
will you vote for this man yeah I've
used tin foil I use have these
headphones so I can listen to music and
when it rains I would just tin foil wrap
it over my head really enjoy that it
would also I get the frequency with
coming better my alibi those eyes aunt
Anna TVs where you get the banana ears
you know that you're going group get 210
boiled yeah what it's trying to get it
you listening I'm no I would put my
headphones on okay and they were not
waterproof right it's back in the 70s
and the 80s so I take tin foil and wrap
my ears you're listening to the radio
listen to the radio in gardening yeah
and so I would be able to get the signal
coming away radio you know there's a
bigger idiot their gardening with the
tempo tonight then one time I used to
get those granny shower caps the polka
dotted one yes before the rainbow colors
came out in the moon and then I will
send here I've got this rainbow hat on
hey I love your hat thank you I love
your hat thank you
oh I love your I'm going along because I
realized what it was so I did change
colors boys been getting honey
yeah there's Noddy you know anybody not
everybody but that's another thing that
makes you want to go hmm I'm a chick
magnet right come on give us you mug you
know that's a good what does he mug is
chick magnet can we easy
all right let's do a another quick
little read break and then dance can
come in with the news Dana that's a good
centimeter news
let's hit it up
thank you to our sponsors who help
support the show make it possible thanks
to them we got to bring out your
wonderful guests like Rudy the legend
thank you very much bye-bye I may not
say goodbye but by the sponsors good
thank you
it's a free market system but go buy it
anyway you heard it here so help first I
want to say which one are we doing we
got the black tux here there are so many
options in life to wear tux so when your
big day or special event rolls around in
summer look just as great as you feel
with suits from the black tux calm with
high quality rental suits and tuxedos
delivered to your front door the black
stuck gives you a new way to rent plus
with this free home try on you can see
the fit and feel the quality of your
suit months before your event and the
best part it's done completely online
black tux lets you create your look
these suits usually cost 1205 dollars
and it's are actually a really
interesting service you hit him up
before the bar mitzvah always bar
mitzvahs uncle to any other event other
than that mm-hmm you can yep obviously
right and you hit them up you work on
your look you pick out the perfect suit
and it will arrive 14 days before the
event so you can try it on make sure it
works perfectly they're going to tailor
it to you they got the support you need
and it ships free both ways how easy is
that my
standout at your event for the right
reasons get $20 off your purchase visit
the black tux comm / h3 that's black tux
comm / h3 get $20 off your purchase it's
actually really cool they sent us here
so you judge you tailor it you try it on
they send you all the parts you got the
undershirt you got the jacket again two
undershirts you got pants you got
cricket what size of those you choose
what guys man I'd be looking good
tonight okay should at all when I do you
201 you choose the size online then you
got dumb this is the whole freaking
thing about sharing with amazing the
bowtie the shooter it's for 95 bucks
cheap it's a rental you don't have to
fuss we're going to the sort so if you
have a big event coming up and I think
they tailor it for you too they do all
that they make it fit for you perfectly
oh man I'm telling you tell you what we
need to head out to those Bar Mitzvahs
what specific size of those Bar Mitzvahs
hmm not a evening magazine next week so
maybe I should order one of those two
words or evening magazine oh so you know
I'm just probably I guess but like going
in with a black touch it's a full-on tux
that you rented for $25 in supporting h3
and everything that matters we all
batter
I'd love to see you when it sucks I'm
going to get one you can visit them by
going to the black tux comm / h3 get $20
off your first purchase guys if you have
an event where you're trying to look
dapper and fresh as heck consider using
this service and help support the show
appreciate you and finally we have been
0 here we go
this is actually a really beautiful
watch I've been wearing it fine Italian
leather you can tell us what if it's
small
it's blue I've never seen balloon
weather but I like it a lot it's got a
really classy huge front it feels like a
nice Gertie heavy valuable watch give
coppaFeel we go good with my glasses
Purdue that's fashion in your outfit
fashion put that on the team bring my
matter to the foil and I'm going to play
watches okay you know time is a
globalist construct time it does edits
through us I've got nothing to do it
actually the share to the earth yeah
that's art artists for real in stairs a
luxury watch like it let me see if that
actually looks great looks good
you know what you want it yeah all your
gifts to you writing that's yours with
memorabilia it's then going home again
yeah but we did we have your bag I'll
buy more
that's yours goes with blue star again
blue Friday gouache dan just shut it
down the stream has to be if I love it
thank you though thank you very much
thank you Vince arrow will get thick you
Vince arrow pretty chill oh hey forget
about it there are a couple of this
email but jeridolp I said oh email while
hitting my watches so here's the deal
with Vince hero did any show it are you
showing the watches Dan show the watches
please a mama way to a very end I've got
a tux I gotta watch that I'm tied for
this base of our mittens was coming up
my nephew's get man so here's the deal a
watch of this quality would usually run
you freaking thousands these one at
least like several hundred right but
Advent zero they start at what like 95
bucks or something like that
yes I'm doing that one of those yeah
dude give coppaFeel man it's really high
worldly stuff here's another man that is
pretty much like the zeros years of
manufacturing experience allows them to
create innovative and luxurious
timepieces and deliver them for a
ridiculously fair price
I've actually worn it to a dinner we
went to meet some super important people
and I wore to a dinner and they're like
oh my god
ethan drop trou right now like that
watch is insane
drop your pants want to touch your
wiener because that watch and people are
forgetting me is how i do the bar
mitzvah yes it was it was a bit after
barman is but it's crazy with his watch
does it look so beautiful guys it's got
a 24 month warranty warranty three
thousand five star reviews so when you
head out to your next bar mitzva go to
Vince arrow VI and see ero collective
calm /h 3 and get 15% off your very own
din Siro watch that's the eye and see
ero collective calm /h 3 guys if you're
in the market for a very affordable
luxurious beautiful watch that is got
all the quality and less the price
consider picking that up to support the
show and thank you very much for what's
that well the spans link all the links
panelist you know Aegon helps after
doing an ad like that you go you won't
into the mic a bunch of times it gets
people to do it works with every Walt I
bet you won't won't you won't oh I watch
you won't know what yeah it's a good way
to advertise right so you won't you
won't matter you won well okay so don't
do it but do it well you won't you won't
though we want you to that so sport our
sponsor you want thank you guys for
chillin with us what did they want to
just jump right into the dance new
segment yeah okay all right cool so
we're probably going to get what should
I just go to a break so we have time to
get it set up okay well we won't leave
but it'll just be like for the video
like that
alright so we're going to stay here but
imma cut it for like the final so we'll
be back in just a minute with Dan's send
me the news it's just news now alright
okay we're going to get set up welcome
back everybody to the h3 podcast now
with the much-anticipated segment send
me the nudes news featuring Dan I think
I wouldn't do that
[Music]
I just wouldn't do that and throw up
there all right it's still so taking a
break we're not saying there's not
another right right it's not a break
this is real talk about taking a break
look there's less delay than I thought I
can't get it uh oh yeah well you need to
but it's kind of tripping me out how
little delay there is I thought there'd
be like a 30-second one at least with
like two seconds
all right come I mean look roll the
intro again no I'm kidding
what is this [ __ ] jealous all right
let's get right into the news in the
news we're doing the news yet to go just
go let's get right into the news on the
news news no no yes yes all right one
job all right so you know nothing is
completely batshit insane as our Kelly's
sex cult for money no but some pretty
good stuff this week here's the first
one you guys heard anything about the
the Discovery Channel special with
Michael Phelps this next week
No so they hyped it up pretty majorly we
had this then mine because were Michael
Phillips then the you got to put the mic
in here I'm going to put it right in my
mouth you can turn up the volume on the
input out on the mixer - yeah that
should be good that should be good so
yeah so they hype this all up that
Michael Phelps was oh yeah irony turns
out the shark with CGI yep
what yeah they kind of pulled a bait and
switch that is so soft but why would I
ride so much money marketing that's a
spectacular thing Michael Phelps racing
a shark
yeah and that's CGI it well it's a
computer-generated shark based on you
know okay estimated speed of a shark
it's a total closed area sounds like I
have TV quickly well it's gonna take
your unfasten aided by how they're gonna
figure
that one I yeah I think have like split
tanks do they put bait at the other end
to make man and people like really
trying to sell this is being real people
complain that side by side in an ocean
there's no way Michael Phelps get out
swim of shark there's no [ __ ] way
well you're not wrong and that's kind of
my favorite part of that this whole
thing is after all this hype he lost
obviously you're talking about a shark
in the ocean where she got really should
not have come as a spelled everyone
thought it's like a multi multi-million
dollar tonnage instead I just think like
who cares about a CGI shark just tell me
you can calculate right how fast it goes
actually how fast right really exact or
a joke just now this is also going to
boil down to a 10 seconds like he lost
by 10 seconds like oh you think there
must have been like a boardroom meeting
somewhere where they're like guys got an
idea right Michael Phelps make them
range of shark and they're like oh we
love it and then they went and do it
they're like I'm sorry [ __ ] what do you
think I mean how many years has
Discovery Channel been doing Shark Week
now they're not yeah how much is there
because it we say about shark was this a
shark tank mate or shark week name yeah
part of a part of Shark Week and you
know they've been doing this for like 20
years now or something and it's like
we've explored sharks like move in on
the week monkey which is really gonna
learn about a lot about monkey yeah this
shit's kind of triggering me i think
that like you're saying this kala
correct the decks of executives and
they're like this is where we're going
to spend all the money let's get a shark
up against Michael Phelps obviously is
gonna lose a [ __ ] shark but also I
feel like they there was a way to kind
of arrange it right like we didn't like
put I don't know yet build it is built
down the lane width of a shark like two
super long tanks or whatever I would
have been dull but already separated in
the middle like a swimmable tube yeah
just a short of water
yeah no it's wonderful to know that
problem is the idea right
sound to begin with right you're already
gonna do it let me see this dumbass
garbage
it has anybody used a headline it's a
bait-and-switch yet hopefully you know
it I thought my beer I don't want to
leave that he's keeping pace with that
show
oh it's got a spin yeah they gave him a
dolphin spin first that's not regulation
wait did it just heat them [ __ ]
evening.you he lost like two seconds not
first of all I'm gonna leave I don't
even believe that it looks okay it's
closer than I would have guessed
it's a CGI it's CGI I think a real shark
would it's melted that you know I'm
pissed
hopefully the next one doesn't raise my
head Russian troll sharks gotta race
Phelps we doesn't have a brain of his
honor it's a conspiracy sharks aren't
real
no I understand that but I mean if it
was a real shark I was how would you get
the shark to race them well that was
what they was so excited because they're
like I wanted to find that out too
yeah but then it was just a freakin CGI
sorry does anybody know how to talk to a
shark Samuel Jackson decided the D flew
soon movie oh you want to be presented
with an abstract native sorry commander
had a Willie we were always trying to
talk to the Willie to see if the Willie
would talk to the the fake wetlands yeah
and they were trying to talk to a
plastic plastic or Coca fibers on an
engine so they did we assumed maybe a
work because we had a few spooks so
somewhere between the fiberglass
goddess and Willie had some sort of
thing going on so that was just the
homeless guy inside the whale who's out
there
get me out of there okay put a sandwich
in this thing something
what time the well got the whale they
thought that whale had gotten loose and
that the sea lands were entangled with
the Willy but we had the whale out of
the water and healthy lions rest as they
rest with their fin floating in the
along the of above the waterline and I
didn't know that but now I know that
it's all because of the Willy with Thank
You Willy if you had a like a sea lion
problem you would get a giant Orca and
like put it a scarecrow just get it out
guys we use or used to hear that he'll
boot up we got a few spooks but not
really I see a back road and it was very
seal scarce he'll scare still scare
still I was on deck all right next up
this actually is appropriate for your
conspiracy closet here doesn't need an
insurance company in Wisconsin that has
announced that they are going to be
microchipping all of their employees
nothing wrong with that all right
oh that illegal so that what so it is
voluntary before I get too upset but
basically it is a company that they sell
like vending machines and they're trying
to implement this whole thing where
everybody you know their vision of the
future is everybody has a microchip in
their hand and you swipe it over you
know a sensor or something and that's
how you pay for it you got your credit
card they're great you're heading over
there it's like boom right right in your
hand that's when I woke up with a
[ __ ] scanner and take all your money
hey how are you put within people a
right shake like they have like credit
card stealers in their hand and you're
like hey how you doing your hand oh look
you've got your honor Pay Pal it says
like Eric I love the future woman it's
coming and it's on PayPal it says got
him - Adam - by Erik LLC so yeah they're
putting these microchips in order to you
know kind of use the employees as a
guinea pig to demonstrate out how
awesome this could be did they pay them
I'm probably not so much any bonus
heisting well you get your breach if
she's innocent
amazing technology for free get to test
it on your body are you guys well what's
what's insane about all this is beyond
the fact that they're doing it at all
I've actually seen somebody get one of
these yes this year it was like kind of
a thing that like a lot of people you
know all these companies want to move
towards microchip people and the gun
it's like straight out of a sci-fi movie
it's like this huge like I don't know it
kind of looks like a picture of it
yeah I'm pulling it up this huge needle
it's pretty intimidating usually check
this out oh and anything in there like
fish check that one because they've been
shipping animals for a long yeah so they
just but this is like a new thing but
that's what it looks like that's what
the human version laughs I got a chip
the fish using try that they can that
needle in a good luck change yeah and
because I got to get it deep like pretty
much on your bone and so it's like [ __ ]
get chips or babies so yeah like
circumcision you got to get that one
your baby yeah right in your dick right
and then like I'll put my arm in like a
microwave or something to get rid of it
when I'm older that's what the
resistance yes that's right we found the
only microwave in North America Skyler
come to the resistance spelling pole on
the side because when you open the door
it turns off we've rigged this thing
it's really unsafe but I'll get that
ship out of it kind of like a mark of
Honor
well that wasn't like kind of shriveled
slackened hand I hope they don't have
the same properties as cat poop or you
start to taste the chip after a while my
god cave yeah I'll put a chip in a cat
no we can't do that they so it says each
chip costs 300 what do you get like as a
chip recipient what is the per click on
the credit card it's in your body that
forever none that's what they're
offering now like what are they offering
now I wouldn't do it I mean that's the
thing is when you think about it's like
okay so you have this chip and you're
able to go up to the vending machine and
swipe your hand and pay for your snack
what what anything that you can't
already do it says employees will be
able to
is the chip to get into the front door
and log on to their computers right
that's that's about that means bigger
than them I'm sign-in yeah it's a really
bad proposition sign into your computer
you're saying they put it between your
yeah right there some unfortunate sweaty
area here that's where that water I that
I will get it grew it up no soil
what about face recognition why do I
know the chip will get read to and
you're like damn it max
all right that's a these guys are ass
versa ah it says there's no GPS tracking
at all but you can ship I like RF we're
gonna take a week from the way that
there yeah you put it no ever Road
editors in a room you can figure out
where someone that's like that level
ever wrote it is like there's no GPS
tracking at all he said it's a way he
said everything I said yeah this makes
it a GPS tracking whatsoever
that's scary wink well there's already a
GPS tracker on all of us and our phones
what do you need to implant for yeah
it's good point but that's the thing is
what what benefit are you really getting
out of this that you don't already have
you can log into your computer again you
know it takes 30 days to it takes 30
days to recover and there's a small risk
of losing your hand to infection but
I'll take a beer
your bones will vibrate your every time
you get a full have cat [ __ ] in your
mind there's no way about it alright so
you won't have a choice okay oh man not
a run wrong I guess let's move on
running my internship right nothing
alone on mungus okay here's something a
little bit more lighthearted
they they recently unburied Salvador
Dali tamama do it like a paternity test
and I guess whatever they did his
moustache his iconic moustache has been
perfectly preserved and certainly yeah
like 30 years later they dig him out and
he looks pretty much just like this what
kind of gel is he using yes that's what
I wanted it's a good [ __ ] some pomade is
that the story uh yeah there's one
little thing they mentioned when they
laid eyes and
I love how they yeah what is something
of this Court's golly I would like to
see his [ __ ] I think he would have
liked us to it yeah they just really it
would have been up his alley they
chipped yesterday doesn't that except in
all of our bodies now after we die just
to make sure but there was actually like
a lot of excitement about this the heart
community and my favorite quote from
this article is you know the the person
who was responsible said his face was
covered with the silk handkerchief of
magnificent handkerchief a Prada was
just hankered yeah I don't know
handkerchief was completely raggedy ANNs
Oh bug his much upper for this
estimation a do that only because I
might have killed like a turd all around
the place I can make dig me up can die
just like put out there late and being
famous doesn't stop them either but I
guess Finch I wish I had known that is
he's a little I like just to get a
pineapple hair cutter before you die I'm
making the movie they're going to fire
me into space I'll be the first
satellite well your bones will be left
and then just a moment dig him up and be
like oh my god you still got his glasses
that would be that is my luck look how
these were like 10 years 10 voters those
are made I haven't shaved I've burned my
eyes and hedges in Seattle and and my
eyes become light-sensitive and so I've
got these glasses when I had them ever
since they look safety Bono I get
flipped a lot of stuff but who cares
okay poker player that's what I've ever
said I look like a cop because a taxi
driver can pick me up today so I mean
that's a new one
I bet sorry I'm nervous this life I
guess is the ice no he's an icicle not a
smoke break your iced out and now with
that watch you're not y'all never know
I'm primping what else we got moving you
know keeping it in the in the mustache
Department here did you hear about the
Justice League reshoots
no so they had to reshoot the shitload
of Justice League was that robably
office [ __ ]
and so he was already in another movie
where he needs a mustache so they've
reached a whole movie with him with that
mustache and they are planning on
digitally removing it in post
essentially like a digitally I think
that's a real is that not a shut up [ __ ]
nothing strong mustache white safe
they're going to remove it what is the
reshoot okay so he's he was on the set
of another movie right they are not
Justice League yeah and then they
realized oh this movie's terrible
probably um you know and we need to like
reshoot half of it well I already moved
on like I'm making this awesome movie I
have this mustache but wow they're like
[ __ ] it just let's do it anyways hey you
two figure it out yeah Jeff Sweden's
doing the he's wrapping up the movie
right I think they brought him in to
make it not complete garbage or
something that is pretty wicked I mean I
got it so you should keep it yeah just
keep it look at that isn't it easier to
do a fake mustache for that I move in
and to remove it for this one it's like
like deja Julius twenty million dollars
they have the money to make that deal
you can buy a really nice fake mustache
one day by the way Ben Affleck is
completely CGI in the Justice League
movie he was busy in Thailand they just
had a skeleton and chairs and stuff he
sent over his vocals over Skype yeah
they just have Matt Damon do the whole
movie we're just going to digitally yeah
paint amount that's pretty fascinating
yeah I just [ __ ] picture kid giggle I
wonder when we've got a mustache too
differently I see had a different role
other stuff so we'll move off the
mustaches
we've also got man held men held after
deadly king cobras smuggled into u.s. in
potato chip cans Wow this is a man again
just look at em [ __ ] victory roll up
somebody died because there's one oh uh
apparently a bunch of the cobras died
because I got okay sticking them in a
potato can and throwing it in your check
on not the best way to look at
why would you want to know someone was
smuggling them like yeah like a ton of
like these exotic animals and yeah
somebody I think oh is that lax actually
yeah they you know customs pulled it out
and they popped open this thing and you
know the kangaroo spider jumping out of
the can literally that I said with a
deadly Cobra imagine the guy's face
summiteers like a better obey oh say
something screwy that's time to scream
yeah that's the times we're done and the
thing is one day they've just caught
them so this must be something that was
going on for a while yeah so let's guys
don't catch as it was according to the
article this was you know this is a ring
I was going on from from Asia and the
guy who got caught apparently for doing
this you can go to federal prison for 20
years
Wow [ __ ] around with this but yeah I
guess it was a bunch of turtles a bunch
of snakes and I don't know some other
[ __ ] what do you use cobras for was it
like some medicinal now you just sell
them to kids you go to the lake there's
like rare animal electors yeah people
are okay yeah you get a bunch so that
like at least one will make it yeah yeah
I don't know what shittier the jumping
like catching them or the job of the
smuggling them the guy smuggled it
probably has to pull them out later yeah
is and they've been in there for a day
or two they're not at least they're
famished though you're famished you just
pull you pour them out like a bag of
chips
goodbye idiot and other idiots we're so
much [ __ ] more powerful you know
powerful that is that meditation better
lose their snake I guys a mammal they
had a CG to smile off of everyone's
favorite they're breaking during scenes
during a doctor like this alright and so
last one keeping on the in the animal
kingdom here so these animal rights
activists in where was this Minnesota
they wanted to you know do a an act of
eco-terrorism or whatever to save these
minks you guys know what a mink is take
a little money boy because it is like a
boy this is pretty much just a little
monkey way yeah yeah figure here's
of a mink so cute ass little monkey or
the cutest [ __ ] thing in the world is
this always look at that my my grandma
had a mink it's like a water spirit
monitor very Hannigan's commit that but
you know that thing but flat like our
earth children so yeah so this farm was
for your grandmother basically is for
you know their fur and so these people
that you know then panel rights
activists they want to help out so they
they busted in and they freed forty
thousand minks and relax on a while
somebody caught us 40s at one time they
had of it all they always like release
all the Minnesota yeah and you know and
you know what happened they immediately
all died maybe on the farm better
billion in other news which guiding the
traces brianza minks goes horrible I
stupid what easier way how did they die
so it was really hot and it's emit well
and also yeah this is not their
environment at all and it's forty
thousand animals just being released
into one very small area there's no food
there's no water they would arouse a
environment right yeah they're also
invasive exactly so I was not a problem
everything on every single level this
was a terrible idea
read these things even though they're
[ __ ] adorable that all honey how do
you smell something I smell something I
don't know oh my god I've never seen
this before
what do you imagine you want outside
your house they're big chairs like
golden if I don't know of the Mick
massacre
there's not even want to pay chose to
censor that need to pick I should say
like what you say 40,000 40,000 that's
crazy it must have been a whole field of
yeah yeah no and that's in the article
they're talking about how you know these
animal rights activists you know that
thought they were doing something good
they should you know really come here
and help the people because somebody's
got clean that up too so you know so
there's like the three poor saps the
basically have to spend their weekend
that would be Rudy for valor real really
that mean anything
let's get Rudy to do it Rudy does
anything imagine if a couple just two
people did that do people release them
yeah and has their perpetrators yeah
I'll just set fire to the whole field
Danny one year old man and a 28 or women
be born yeah you know what Shepard chip
them first when they were on daughter
yeah boy sits out they were on a mink
dream road trip
stop freeing the main lock the minks and
I can be real that's Pam 40,000 miles
how big is the earth flat or round they
can buy four thousand ounces
well my belly it was in a straight line
was want to do the zig zagging it's a
really efficient way to Joab Singh
there's Bonnie and Clyde of the Rhoden
world they have to throw the police off
the tail
can you imagine that's your job like how
soul-crushing would that be to just
you're picking up these adorable
creatures [ __ ] rotting corpses 40,000
of them you may be a little too romantic
about it I think it's more like but
basically Unleashed like the this third
sign of the Apocalypse I'm enjoying it
in and out Henry right Alyssa maybe I
should have done lets you order prints
they're on a road trip and they didn't
realize it setting them free kill them
all how many bodies that [ __ ] been
eating a half a car ladders and
pestilence upon the minke community did
they are the harbinger of that yeah no
wonder if they like heard it on the news
afterwards and they're like whispers
sighs probably Helen Allison there was a
mother make is true this is the road to
Gooden tations is paved with the bodies
my goodness
all right anything else no no that's
that's the formation Martha for you all
right so makes a cute though and that
was saying but you're wrong
thank you bravo Bravo thank you Eric for
X yeah
well it was a beta Plaza beta I was fun
I had a lot of fun called an alpha
welcome try the next one will be phasing
out the time I got some real juicy for
next time you guys aren't going to
believe it
Kelly I can't boy well it shocked us you
guys have no idea
go ahead and mix rum [ __ ] dude come on
Sheamus guys I hope you had a lot of fun
this week this was what was it a long
episode so it was a juicy long average
telling 20 minutes to me this was like
nothing so it was definitely it was
definitely like several hours fresh air
well polish this off a whole shark
weekend on Nat Geo wertham you know
whatever coming I gotta race a shark
with you by that I mean just be like
this is how fast you it's when we talk
about his checksums nope she lost okay
ii had a lot of fun
remember all y'all out there who don't
have the money or the means to support
us with our products you can support us
for free by connecting your Amazon Prime
account with your twitch account and you
get one free sub every month it helps us
a lot you get to subscribe for dang free
appreciate that so much
people are saying called Joey I don't
know what we already do I don't know why
they really wanted to chromosome I got
Joey such a phenomenon I got worried
about Joey for you alright we call up
Joey salads sometimes but I don't have
anything to talk to him about these
where you guys just want to know how is
Joey no I when we were talking about
Flat Earth they wanted to hear his
opinion I think about it I'm scared to
find out that's on the chadsey people
seem to be implying he he might be a
believer oh well I mean we've been based
other than thing to it yeah we all did
I mean we're something they're saying
he's a flat earther but I don't believe
it do they know it are they guessing
okay here's what I'm gonna do I'm going
to check with him and then we'll get
McCall nap yeah and follow up stick
around I'm just gonna we're going to
take a break then I'll come back and
read the donations and do a little bit
of after-show for you guys but thanks
again
a lot of fun you can catch some twitch
calm / switch dot TV such an idiot
such a loser can't do it every time as
anyone watch this crap twitch.tv slash
h3h3 productions every Friday at 3 p.m.
Rudy has been a joy a pleasure a
privilege it's been sweet
I spent sweet isn't so great I want to
check out East LA how do I get there
East LA be ready listen what do you want
to know Nate what is what's with these
sellers are so good there's some good
taco trucks oh yeah yeah really jealous
but you get to a Lopez you want to get
some Mexican food tonight yeah that we
could look out meat you gotta run out
here thanks for joining us that was your
how at internet comment etiquette that's
correct
thank you guys for having me we got to
get a little thing where it says your
Twitter to so people can follow Malmo
squared on my shirt hey where's by the
way are 24 kids CLL vote for Hugh is a
vote for you both for humongous for City
Councilman a vote for you is a vote for
you like that just just put it just
pencil it in you don't have to tell
anybody
our secret secret ballot day because
your secret shame humongous Amano sila
legend what up
god bless you whatever you want to be to
sharpen it's my my cell your and then
let's get right into the news dan dan
let's get ring to the nudes appreciate
you excellent job this is the longest
and I want to say is we're all are great
I appreciate you so much and I'm gonna
wrap it up now in about 10 seconds 10 9
8 7 6 5 cut it